Hello Vancouver.
Thank you.
Alright,
so we have an interesting situation
here.
Um,
obviously this is part two and a few of
you were here for what took place last
night.
We're going to find a way to catch you
all up pretty quick on what took place,
but before we do that,
I thought it might make sense to talk to
you about where we are in this
discussion and why it matters and it
matters not just for those of us on
stage,
but it matters very much for you all in
the audience.
The point is basically this,
we've arrived at a place in history
where the sensemaking apparatus,
that usually helps us figure out what to
think about.
Things has obviously begun to come
apart.
The political parties,
the uh,
the university is journalism.
All of these things have stopped making
sense and alternative sensemaking
networks have begun to rise.
And the one that we ended up being a
part of seems to be beating the odds
with respect to staying alive and being
a vibrant part of the conversation.
But that depends on something.
It depends on our ability to upgrade.
What we can discuss and navigate and Sam
and Jordan have run a foul of each other
in the past,
as you all know,
and so our ability to upgrade the
conversation such that they're able to
find common ground and for us to move
forward together is potentially very
important.
A very important upgrade.
Now that upgrade in the modern era
includes you all because our
conversation and your conversations are
all now linked through the Internet.
So the ground rules for tonight involve
you not filming what takes place on
stage tonight.
And the reason for that is because what
takes place on stage tonight has
consequences and the freer that Sam and
Jordan feel to use new tools to try out
positions that maybe they haven't
explored before.
The more likely we are to succeed.
So please don't film,
but that does not mean that we don't
want you talking about what was
discussed here tonight.
In fact,
we're very excited to see what you all
make of this conversation and where it
heads so in an effort to get you up to
speed on where we got yesterday.
And I think the evidence is strong.
We all felt and the discussion online
suggests that we actually accomplished
quite a bit yesterday that we made
headway in an effort to attempt to keep
that momentum going,
but we're going to do is we're going to
have sam and Jordon Steele,
man each other's points from last night
so that you can hear what that sounds
like.
Now,
for those of you who have ever tried
steel manning,
somebody point with whom you have a
severe disagreement,
you know just how hard this is,
so let's give them some leeway.
Sam,
would you be willing to start?
Sure,
sure.
Thank you.
Well,
first let me just make the obvious point
that that probably isn't so obvious once
you take the time to put yourself in our
shoes,
but just imagine how surreal it is for
us to be who we are.
Simply having a conversation about ideas
and to be able to put a date on the
calendar and have all of you show up for
this.
I mean,
it's just an amazing privilege.
Thank you for coming out.
So,
so here's what I think,
Jordan,
things I'm getting wrong.
I think that was grammatically correct.
Maybe there's another note in there,
but clearly I don't understand how
valuable stories are,
how deep they go,
how did the degree to which story is in
code,
not only the wisdom of our ancestors,
but quite possibly the wisdom borne of
the hard knocks of evolution of the
species.
Right,
so there's no telling how deep the
significance of the information encoded
in stories goes and there's a class of
stories that are religious stories and
their religious for a reason because
they're dealing with the deepest
questions in human life.
They're questions about what constitutes
a good life,
what's worth living for,
what's worth dying for.
These are things that if each individual
just thrust from onto the stage of his
own life not knowing where he is and
tasked with figuring out how to live all
on his own or even in a collection of of
others who are similarly unguided by
ancient wisdom,
this is not knowledge we can.
We can recapitulate for ourselves easily
and so we we edit or ignore the these
ancient stories at our apparel at some,
at minimum,
and some considerable risk because we
don't know how much we don't really know
what baby is in the bath water and so we
should have immense respect for these
traditions and the,
this is well,
this has yet to be discovered tonight.
I'm still not quite clear about how this
links up with,
with more metaphysical propositions
about the origins of these have certain
of these stories,
but at minimum my criticism of religion
because it tends to focus on the most
obvious case of a zero sum contest
between religious dogmatism and
scientific open ended discussion is
doesn't address this core issue of the
significance of religious thinking and
religious narrative because I am,
for the most part just shooting fishing
in a barrel,
criticizing fundamentalists,
uh,
and the kind of God that the
fundamentalists believe in the God who
is an invisible person who hates
homosexuals.
Obviously that's not the deep,
the deepest version of these religious,
this or this.
This essentially what is a narrative
technology for orienting human life.
In the cosmos,
so maybe I'll leave it there,
but that's I think what Jordan thinks.
Thanks
for use steel man.
Sam's point.
How did you feel about his encapsulation
of yours?
Well,
I'm convinced.
Yeah,
I mean,
well,
I got a couple of things to say about
it.
It's like,
first of all,
I think it was accurate,
concise,
fair.
I also think that this is a more
technical note in some senses that if,
if you ever want to think about
something that's exactly what you have
to do,
right?
You want to take arguments that are
against your perspective and you want to
make them as strong as you possibly can
so that you can fortify your arguments
against them.
You don't want to make them weak because
that just makes you weak.
And so,
you know,
Sam and I are both scientists and it
really is the case that what scientists
are trying to do.
And I think what we're actually trying
to do in this conversation genuinely is
to try to find out if there's something
that we're thinking that's stupid,
you know,
because when,
when I'm laying out the arguments that
Sam just summarize so well,
I've tried to generate a bunch of
opposition to them in my own
imagination.
And the arguments I put forward are ones
I can't undermine.
But that doesn't mean they're right.
It doesn't mean that at all.
And so if someone comes along who is,
and this is certainly the case,
if you're a scientist who's worth his or
her salt,
if someone comes along and says,
hey look,
you made a mistake in this fundamental
proposition,
it's like,
yes,
great.
That means I can make progress towards a
more solid theory of being so.
And that's what we're trying to do.
And I do think it's working.
And so I thought that was just fine.
Exactly dead on.
And I hope I can do justice to your
position as so.
Okay.
So to summarize Sam's argument briefly
and then I'm going to tell him lately
that you guys know why he thinks I'm
things.
At what things I'm not taking into
account,
so sam believes that there are two
fundamental dangers to psychological and
social stability,
religious fundamentalism essentially on
the right and moral relativism and
nihilism on the left and so the danger
of the right wing position is that it
enables people to arbitrarily
established certain revealed axioms as
indisputable truth and then to
tyrannized themselves and other people
with the claims that those are divine
revelations and he sees that as part of
the danger of religious fundamentalism
and maybe religious thinking in general,
but also as something that characterizes
second or totalitarian states that also
has a religious aspect.
So that's on the right and then on the
left.
Well the problem with the,
with the moral relativism nihilism
position is that it leaves us with no
orientation and it also flies in the
face of common sense observations.
That there are ways to live that are bad
and that there are ways to live that are
good,
that people can generally agree on.
And that statements about those general
agreements about how to live can be
considered factual.
Now so and then the next part of Sam's
argument is that we require a value
system that allows us to escape these
twin dangers.
One stultifies us and the other leaves
us hopeless,
let's say,
and that value system has to be grounded
in something real and the only thing
that he can see that actually
constitutes real in any provable sense
and there's a certain amount of
historical and conceptual weight behind
this claim,
is the domain of empirical facts as as
they'd be manifested in the sciences and
technologies that have made us
incredibly powerful and increasingly
able to flourish in the world,
and so we need to ground our value
propositions in something that we've
been able to determine,
has genuine solidity to so that we can
so that we can orient ourselves properly
so that we can make moral claims and
that we can avoid these two endangers.
We can begin with some basic facts that
we can identify,
as I mentioned very briefly,
what constitutes a bad life.
Endless pain,
suffering,
anxiety,
tremendous amount of negative emotions,
short term lifespan.
All the things that no one would choose
voluntarily for themselves.
If,
if we would all agree that they were
thinking in a healthy manner and we can
contrast that sort of domain of horror
with the good life which might involve
while certainly freedom from privation
and want and undo threat and anxiety and
hope for the future and all of that,
and that we can agree that those are
polls,
good,
bad and good,
and that that's a factual claim,
so he,
Sam also claims that we can define the
good life.
This is an extension of it with
reference to flourishing and wellbeing
and that that that can actually be
measured and that we should and can
inform the idea of flourishing and
wellbeing with empirical data.
Having said all that,
he also a what would a domain of inquiry
open that would be centered on the
possibility that some of the ideas that
have been encapsulated in religious
phenomenology,
if not in religious dogma,
it might be worth pursuing as well.
That there might be wisdom that can
practically be applied in terms of
perception too,
to spiritual practices.
Although those become dangerous,
dangerous,
increasingly dangerous as they become
ensconced in dogma.
And so that's Sam's position,
and then his criticism of my ideas I'm
take,
he would say that it's facts,
not stories that constitute the ground
for the proper science of wellbeing and
that we don't need to be connected to
stories,
ancient stories in particular to thrive
and the reason for that or that these
ancient stories are pathological in
certain details,
especially in this specific claims they
make up,
which,
which looks outrageous in some sense
from a modern moral perspective.
And he believes that it's hand waving to
ignore those specific topics.
And with,
uh,
with uh,
what would you call it,
an optimistic overview of the entire
context that they're dangerously
outdated now,
if they ever were useful,
that they're subject to too many
potential interpretations for any modern
usage to be reliably derived.
And so he believes that attempts to
interpret these stories,
let's say,
are rife with so many potential errors
of bias and interpretation and
subjectivity that all the
interpretations in some sense are
unreliable and perhaps equally
unreliable that their day is that worse
than that.
Not only are they unreliable,
but they're dangerous in so far as the
claims they lay out our pose,
a threat to scientific and enlightenment
values,
which are the true saviors of humanity
as evidenced by our progress,
let's say over the last two or 300
years,
and that they're also susceptible to the
totalitarian interpretation,
which I described earlier,
which confer upon the interpreter a
sense of and then a claim to reveal
truth.
And so I would say that Sam's argument
and his and his criticisms of my
position,
so.
Okay,
so you write my next book.
All right,
thanks Sam.
Feel about that characterization of your
position.
Uh,
certainly close enough to get the
conversation started.
I met.
There's a few the grounding stuff we
have yet to talk about and I'm not as,
I'm not as much a stickler for
materialistic scientific empiricism as I
heard implied there,
but we can,
can,
we can come to that.
Okay.
So hold on.
I think from the point of view of the
audience,
this is a,
this is a good barometer of where we got
to last night and I think actually the
gains are really impressive,
which I have to say is me because
there's something called regression to
the mean.
Now if I catch either one of you
regressing to the mean tonight,
I will hunt you down and I will ridicule
you on twitter tomorrow so you have a
warrant.
Okay.
Right.
So do either one of you wants to now
talk about what was missing from the
other characterization or how do you
want to move?
I think we should
touch this issue of,
of metaphorical truth because I think it
still gets at the distance between us.
Sure.
As a.
and it's happily this is you're afraid
that you have.
You might want to do
prop up this phrase,
why not?
So the idea of metaphorical truth,
which I think actually is the
reconciliation between at least the
points that you guys each started out
with,
is the idea that there are concepts
which are literally false,
that we can falsify in a scientific
rational sense,
but that if you behave as if they were
true,
you come out ahead of where you were if
you behave according to the fact that
they are false.
And so to call these things simply false
is an error in effect.
The universe has left them true in some
sense other than a purely literal one.
And so religions with them according to
actually what you heard from both Sam
and Jordan,
religions would fall into this class of
things.
These are encapsulations of,
uh,
stories and prescriptions that if you
follow them,
irrespective of whether they literally
describe the universe,
you end up with certain advantages that
you may not know why they are there.
But nonetheless,
you are ahead of your,
uh,
your,
your head of your position if you were
to navigate just simply on your,
your perceptions.
That's the concept.
Yeah.
So I think there's a good analogy that
you and I stumbled onto after we did a
podcast together.
You had a,
an analogy about a porcupine that could
shoot its quills,
which many people balked at,
but listener and gave us a better one,
which was the idea that anyone who's
worked with guns at all must've heard
this admonishment to treat every gun as
if it is loaded.
Right?
And you actually last night when I
alleged that you believed in God,
you corrected me.
He said,
no,
you live as if God exists.
Right?
And so this seems like a,
there's a connection here.
So if,
if,
if I had a gun here that I wanted to
show Brett,
if I know anything about guns,
I'm going to make damn sure that is
unloaded,
right?
I'm going to pull back the slide.
I'm gonna,
drop the magazine,
pulled back the slide,
check the chamber and do this in a
redundant fashion that that really looks
like I'm suffering from obsessive
compulsive disorder.
Maybe if it is truly redundant and then
I'll hand it to Brad and Brett knows
anything about guns.
He will do the same thing,
having just seen me do it and if he
hands it back to me again,
I will do the same thing even though
there,
there may be no ammunition around.
Right?
So it really is crazy at the level of
our explicit knowledge of the situation
and yet absolutely necessary to do.
And it's,
it's not merely,
it's,
it runs very deep.
I mean,
I would even add to that whole time,
you were careful not to point the barrel
of the gun at anything you would be
afraid to shoot.
And when people fail to live this way
around guns,
they with some frequency actually shoot
themselves or people close to them by
accident.
Uh,
so it is really the only proper hedge
against just the,
the,
the odds of being in proximity to,
to loaded weapons.
And yet if someone in the middle of this
operation came up to us and said,
you know,
actually there's a casino that just
opened across the street that will take
your bets about whether or not guns are
loaded.
Would you like to bet a million dollars
as to whether or not this gun is loaded?
Well,
of course I would bet those million
dollars every time that it's not loaded
because I know it's not loaded.
So there's.
There's a,
there's a literal truth and a
metaphorical truth where you know
otherwise known as a very useful
fiction,
which in this case is actually more
useful than the truth.
Right?
But the only way I can understand its
utility is,
and,
and even utter the phrase metaphorical
truth in a way that is comprehensible is
in the context of distinguishing it from
literal truth.
And
Go ahead.
This is fascinating Sam.
Actually this is,
this is I think next year.
I'm a little worried by how excited you
are.
So I have a story that might be helpful
about that.
And so you could,
you could tell me what you think about.
Okay.
Think about this.
So,
so one of the things that I've been
reconsidering since we talked last night
is,
is the nature of our dispute about the
relationship between facts and values.
Because I think I can make a case that
what I've been trying to do,
especially in my first book,
was to ground values in fact,
but I'm not doing it the same way that
you are.
Exactly.
So.
So I,
I don't want to make that a point of
contention so.
And I'll get to that moment.
But with regards to this metaphorical
truth,
let me tell you something.
You tell me what you think about this.
So one of them,
things that's been observed by
anthropologists worldwide is that human
beings tend to make sacrifices.
So I'm going to spend two minutes,
three minutes laying out a sacrificial
story.
And the reason I want to do it is
because see what I think happened with
regards to the origin of these profound
stories is that people first started to
behave in certain ways that had a
survival significance.
And that was selected for.
And as a consequence of,
of,
of this standard
selection practices.
And so that was instantiated,
didn't behavior.
And then because we can observe
ourselves because we're self conscious
creatures,
that we started to make representations
of those patterns and dramatize them.
And then encapsulate them in stories,
so it's a bottom up from the.
So it would be sort of like chimpanzees
or wolves become aware of their
dominance hierarchy structures and the
strategies that they use.
So a wolf,
for example,
if two wolves are having a dominance
dispute,
one the wolf that gives up first lays
down and puts his neck open so the other
wolf can tear it out.
And then the other wolf doesn't.
And you could say,
well,
it's as if a wolf is following a rule
about not killing a weaker member of the
pack.
Of course wolves don't have rules,
they have behavioral patterns,
but a self conscious wolf would watch
what the wolves were doing and then say,
well,
it's as if we're acting out the idea
that each wolf in the pack has intrinsic
value.
And then that starts to be maybe that
wolves would have a little story about
the heroic for bearing wolf that doesn't
tear out the neck of its opponents and
that that's good.
Well,
that's good wolf ethics and,
and,
and so,
but it's grounded,
but it's grounded in the actual
behavior.
Okay.
So let's,
we'll put that aside for a second.
Now here,
here's the sacrificial story to human
beings have made sacrifices.
It seems to be a standard practice all
around the world and in the biblical
narratives,
they would often sacrifice something of
value like a,
like a valuable animal or like a child
start.
Well,
no,
no.
Look,
look,
I'm not.
I'm not making light of this.
I know that human sacrifice was a part
of this.
Yeah,
but that again,
so just to give you a crib on where my
mind goes,
there is human.
Human sacrifice is as old a religious
precept as we know about as a cultural
universal.
The other sacrifices are derivations
from Ed and circumcision is a surrogate
for the far more barbaric act of human
sacrifice and you know it,
it answers every test you would put to
it with respect to its archetypal
significance and it's,
it's compelling a presence in stories
across all cultures,
but the horror is that it actually has
taken place in all these cultures based
on explicit beliefs in the presence of
just just right Arthur scientific
ignorance.
Flirt used that as the argument for the
essential insanity of humanity.
We have nobody.
It's not just the insanity of humanity,
it's the misapprehension of the causal
structure of the cosmos.
You don't know what the weather.
You don't know why people get sick.
You think your neighbor is capable of
cast a magic spell.
It's on you.
You're ignorant of everything and you're
trying to force some order on things,
and so when you don't in the absence of
engineers and you don't know why bill
certain buildings fall down,
you actually can agree with your
neighbor that maybe you should barrier
first born child into every post hole of
this new building,
which in fact has took place and it's
the consequence of ignorance and so that
the problem is if you're only going to
talk about this notion of sacrifice,
very strange consequence of ignorance
like you.
It's the notion that we're in
relationship to invisible others that
can,
that can mistreat us based on not having
offered enough were we are.
We're not precisely those others well,
but we're in relationship to the
invisible others who will judge us in
the future.
So again,
you're changing,
you're changing the noun in important
way,
but I'm also trying to understand,
I'm not trying to argue against the
horror of child sacrifice.
No,
I would never imagine,
but I'm also.
But I'm also find out what my work would
be much easier if you did that.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And,
and the work of journalists as well,
they've tried that.
Pretty much anyone,
right?
That would be,
that would even be worse than enforced
monogamy.
Hypothetical.
So,
okay.
So see,
I'm,
let's say that I'm trying to give the
devil his due and I'm trying to
understand from an evolutionary
perspective,
like cognitive behavioral evolutionary
let's say why that particular set of
ideas would emerge and in many,
many,
many places perhaps autonomously or once
having emerged would spread like
wildfire.
It's like,
because I'm not willing to only
attribute it to ignorance,
now we can attribute it to ignorance.
No problem man,
but,
but there's more going on there because
it is a human universal and like there's
all sorts of things that happened in
nature as a consequence of biological
and evolutionary processes that don't
work out well for our current state of
moral intuition,
like saying,
okay,
so one of the things,
because I've been thinking about this
sacrificial motif for a very long time,
trying to figure out what that,
what,
what the hell's the idea here?
Exactly.
And so,
so here's,
here's one way of thinking about it.
If you give up something of value,
now you can gain something of more value
in the future.
Okay?
So let's think about that idea for a
minute.
So the first thing is that's an,
that's a hell of an idea.
That's delayed,
delayed,
delayed gratification,
right?
That's the discovery of the future as
well.
And so you might say,
well,
the notion of sacrifice is exactly the
same thing as the discovery of the
future.
If we give up something we really value,
now we can make a pact with the
structure of existence itself such that
better things will happen to us in the
future.
Now,
okay,
now what's weird about this,
and it's hard to understand is that it
works.
So when I talked to my students,
for example,
and I say,
what did your parents sacrifice to send
you to university?
Many of them are children are first
generation immigrants and so like,
man,
they're on that story in a second,
right?
They know all sorts of things that their
parents sacrificed and they're delaying
gratification in the present for a
radically delayed return in the future.
Now you think animals,
generally speaking,
they might act out the idea of delayed
gratification as a consequence of
running out their instincts,
but they don't conceptualize it.
It's not obvious that animals give up
something they valued right now in order
to thrive in the future.
There's an old story about how to catch
a monkey,
right?
So you put a jar up with rocks in it.
Then you put little candies and it's a
narrow neck jar.
You put little candies on top of the
rocks,
but if you candies in front of the of
the jar,
then the monkey comes along and picks up
the candies,
puts his hand in the jar,
grabs the candies,
and can't get it out.
I still don't know if this actually
works on monkeys or it's just a great
story.
I don't know.
I don't know either and that I've heard.
I've heard,
I've heard various claims,
but.
But the point is you can go pick up the
monkey.
He won't let go of the candidates.
Now perhaps he would,
but the.
The,
the issue is,
is that it's not obvious that animals
will forgo and immediate gratification
for a future gratification.
Now that don't think.
I don't think that's right actually,
and I actually want to hold the question
is,
will they do it consciously?
They might act it out.
They act it out.
That's not the issue.
It's very hard to know if it's conscious
because they won't respond to the
questionnaires,
but I know,
I know obviously the,
the line between acting it out and
becoming,
starting to consciously represented is a
tenuous one.
But what looks to me like what happened
is that after we observed that people
who were capable of delaying
gratification,
sacrifice things that they valued in
order to obtain a future goal,
and it work,
that we started to codify that as a
representation and then started to act
it out.
And so,
so the story and,
and you'd say,
well that produced strange variance,
but,
but there's a reason for that too,
as far as I can say.
So imagine this,
imagine that there's a rule of thumb
sacrificing what you find valuable now
will ensure certain benefits in the
future.
Well then the question becomes how good
could those future benefits be?
And so that might be heavenly,
let's say in the archetypal extreme and
what's the ultimate sacrifice that you
have to perform?
And then I would say,
well,
the child sacrifice fits into that
category.
And so it's,
it's as if those ideas were pushed to
the radical extreme.
And you could say,
well that's a pathological extreme.
It's like,
well it is,
it is a pathological extreme.
But,
but I think we also have to understand
that some of the things that we've
learned as we've evolved towards our
current state of wisdom such as it is,
is that they were learned in a very
bloody and catastrophic way.
They were learning with incredible
difficulty and delay of gratification
was certainly one of those because it's
a hell of a thing to learn when you're
in conditions of privation.
Okay?
Yeah.
I think that the issue here for me is
that you don't need a conception of.
You don't need any kind of positive
gloss on human sacrifice as a meme or as
an archetype in order to form a coherent
picture of the future that can motivate
you.
So delayed,
delayed gratification is fully separable
from a notion that it might ever be
rational or good to sacrifice a child as
an offering to an invisible other
that doesn't exist.
How do you know it's separate will?
Because that's the developmental
history,
as you said.
Well,
that so sacrifice,
and I think it is in fact historically
separable,
but let.
Let's just say it's not.
Let's just say as a matter of our
origins,
they're united,
they're of a piece,
it's just,
it is the genetic fallacy to care about
that origin.
I mean to say that the that is the only
path forward toward an ocean of the
future,
given where we've come from or that it's
somehow necessary to to venerate now or
that it's.
But we do venerate the idea of sacrifice
now,
but I would say
we do a to to the detriment of our moral
intuitions in the religious context.
So for instance,
I think that the notion that
Christianity,
Christianity is actually a cult of human
sacrifice.
It Christianity is not a religion that
repudiates human sacrifice.
Christianity is a religion that says,
actually no human sacrifice is necessary
and there was only one that in fact was
necessary and effective and that's the
sacrifice of Jesus.
And I think that is when you dig into
the details,
a not only a morally uninteresting
vision of our circumstance and how we
are,
how we can be redeemed,
it's morally a parent,
right?
So I think there's a better version.
Okay.
Let me ask you a question about that.
So in,
in,
in the moral landscape,
you lay out this pathway,
there's the bad life and there's the
good life,
right?
And you described what they were at.
The bad life is a variation of hellish
circumstances.
In the good life is a variant of
hypothetically the life that we would
like to lead.
And your conception is that,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
your conception is that the proper
pathway forward.
So that would be the moral endeavor is
to move away from the bad and towards
the good.
Yeah.
And so far as we understand which way is
up,
yes,
yes.
The basic claim is that we can be right
or wrong with respect to,
to release.
We don't necessarily know how to do that
in an uncaring manner and we could
subject that to approximation correction
along the way and we should.
But we can outline the broad scheme
which is progressive way from hell
towards something that's positive.
Yes.
Okay.
So I would say that there is an implicit
claim in that,
that you should sacrifice everything in
you that isn't serving that to that.
And I would say that that's essentially
the same claim that's made in
Christianity.
Well,
again,
that is a,
I understand the impulse to up level
these ignorance derived beliefs,
right?
To something that is morally that is
interesting and palatable in the current
context.
And I understand you can do that.
My concern there is you can do that with
everything.
I mean you could do it with witchcraft.
Why not do the exact same thing you're
doing with religion to the history of
witchcraft.
Witchcraft is as,
as,
as well,
Margaret Lynch's would do that.
So that's a perfectly valid yet.
But so it's.
But it's a.
That should be of concern me that there
are reasons why we don't want to endorse
them.
Modern witchcraft,
right?
Absolutely.
And so,
so you know,
when you're talking to and monitor
witchcraft currently exists.
I mean,
you go to Africa,
they're there.
People are hunting albinos for their
body parts because they believe in
sympathetic magic kit and kids get
killed as witches.
So this belief endures in certain
pockets of humanity.
And we're right to it.
I just think at a certain point you have
to acknowledge that some ideas are not
only wrong,
but they're,
their effects are disastrous or have
been disastrous or will likely be even
if good in certain circumstances will
likely be disastrous in the future.
And then we shouldn't be hostage to
these,
these ancient memes.
We shouldn't have to figure out how to
make the most of the worst idea that
anyone's ever had,
which is you should make,
you should sacrifice your first born
child to
and you've never seen.
Hold on Sam.
I want to hold your feet to the fire
here.
Okay.
Two points.
One interesting observation.
When you presented the example,
so on your podcast,
I had argued that,
uh,
believing that porcupines can throw
their quills might protect you from a
porcupine.
That might we'll around even though
porcupines can't throw their quills,
your listener sent the better example,
which was all guns are loaded.
When you presented it,
you didn't say all guns are loaded.
Well,
you said treat all guns as if they are
loaded,
which is I think,
the same or reflects that you have faced
with any metaphorical truth,
which is that it can always be unpacked,
but it's actually.
That's the way Jordan talks about
believing in God as well.
Right,
and actually so,
so this is.
But then if we take something like a
you,
so you say,
right,
sacrifice of children is abhorrent,
let's say it is,
and then you say,
well,
Christianity hasn't a foregone the
sacrifice of children.
In fact it's described one child who is
sacrificed for everybody else,
but arguably that's an upgrade of some
metaphorical truth that freeze those who
are adhering to this tradition from ever
considering sacrificing your child and
what it does is it provides a
motivational structure that may in fact
have very positive outgrowths though not
literal.
The idea that someone would have
sacrificed their own child for the
benefit of everybody else,
not to have to.
That idea might engender a large amount
of good work that would result as
Jordan.
Let me just concede that the hardest
case for me,
I met with,
which I did up top just in defining when
after you define metaphorical truth and
I use the gun example,
there's certainly cases where the useful
fiction is more useful than the truth.
I would grant that,
but I think those cases are few and far
between,
but handling guns is one of them.
It's just not useful when the.
When the casino opens across the street
and you can play some million dollar
bet,
right?
Then you want,
you want to have some purchase on the
literal truth so you want to be able to.
And again this is psychologically
interesting because,
and I keep coming,
coming back to the gun example because
the one that that is viscerally real to
me,
like if I have a real gun that I know to
be unloaded,
I still emotionally can't treat it as a
harmless object.
I can't pointed at my child just for the
fun of it because you know that we're
going to play cops and robbers and now
with a real gun,
right?
This,
this.
I have A.
I have a superstitious attachment to
always being safe with a gun,
right,
edit,
and it's important.
It's important that that gets ingrained
and yet it is not strictly raw if it's
not irrational because it has good
effects,
but it's not actually in register with
what I know to be true factually in each
moment.
Right?
So very low cost,
very low cost,
very low cost.
It's not divided societies and causing
people to go to war
and if you were going to teach a child
gun safety,
you would want to encode this so that
they would automatically know never to
behave as if a gun is unloaded because
that's what gets you into trouble as an
adult.
Every,
every gun owner recognizes the
distinction between the metaphorical
truth in the literal truth here,
but I guess what I suspect is going on
here is that your mechanism for dealing
with the world involves unpacking all of
these things and I think it's highly
productive,
but it also means that you have a hard
time understanding why anybody would do
anything different.
And that's the question is just because
we can track fully the difference
between guns.
Actually all being loaded and behaving
as if all guns are loaded,
right?
That one,
there's no leftover,
there's nothing,
there's no mystery there,
right?
But there may be many of these things
for which there is some difficulty
lining up the metaphorical truth with
the literal truth and operating
according to the metaphorical truth
might have advantages,
which I think is what your getting at so
well.
So here's,
here's another situation,
because you know,
we have to remember what kind of
catastrophic past we emerged from.
How much privation ruled the world prior
to 18,
95 essentially,
and certainly
the farther back you go,
the more bloody and horrible it was.
I mean,
how often do you think it was necessary,
and this is not obviously something I'm
in favor of and this is also one of
these situations where we get to play
with ideas that we might not otherwise
play with.
How often do you think it was necessary
for people in the past who had
absolutely no access to birth control
and who didn't have enough food to
sacrifice a child for the survival of
their family mean God only knows and
that's it?
Well,
but that's worth thinking about.
It's like,
you know,
life is unbelievably cruel and difficult
and one of the problems that comes when
you discover the future is that you
might have to make the most painful of
sacrifices and lots of lots of archaic
people do this sort of thing.
They do that with their elderly people.
They do that with sick people.
They do that with infants that they
deemed too fragile to survive like so
part of child sacrifice,
and I know the literature on child
sacrifice reasonably well.
Part of child sacrifice seemed to emerge
out of the observable necessity to leave
someone behind so that everyone else
didn't die and we don't know how often
that had to happen in the past.
It might've had to happen a lot.
Right now,
obviously just just in the interest of
kind of conceptual clarity here,
human sacrifice is a larger horror than
that,
so you have.
It was very common is the sacrificing of
other captives.
They didn't take the Aztec sacrifices
where you,
you now have slaves,
some of whom you're going to have.
The aztecs sacrificed about 25,000
people a year.
Yeah,
look,
I mean it's clearly a bloody mess.
There's no doubt about that,
but you know,
one of the things that you see happening
in the biblical narrative,
which is extraordinarily interesting is
that you see echoes of child sacrifice
at the beginning,
but what happens is the sacrificial
notion gets increasingly psychologized
as the story progresses.
So you know,
you see that transition with Abraham and
Isaac were the were the sec or the child
sacrifice is actually forbidden,
although previously demanded by God and
then you also see it as you already laid
out in the substitution of the
circumcision for the idea of sacrifice
itself and then what seems to happen.
See,
I'm trying to figure out how these ideas
developed site psychologically from
their behavioral underpinnings is that
eventually it becomes psychologized
completely so you can say,
well,
we can.
We can conceptualize a sacrifice in the
abstract so my parents can sacrifice to
send me to university without anything
or anyone having to die.
It transforms itself from something
that's enacted out as a dramatic ritual
into something that's a psychological
reality,
but all that blood and catastrophe along
the way as part of the process by which
the idea comes to emerge.
So what is the connection of all of this
because so there there is this history
and I would argue we are busily trying
to outgrow much of it,
if not most of it,
and whether its evolutionary history or
just trying to transmute it so that it
becomes.
We can,
we can maintain as you suggested,
we do.
We can maintain what's useful in the
tradition and throw out everything
that's pathologic.
Yes,
but we're constantly discovering a lack
of fit between both our,
what we perceive ourselves as biological
imperatives and the cultural legacies of
just what Mommy and daddy taught me was
true,
right,
which we have now.
Every reason to believe might not be
true and we're trying to optimize our
thoughts and institutions and and
relationships with one another for our
current circumstance,
and yet we have this legacy effect of
certain books and certain ways of
speaking have a completely different
status and they have the status because
they may in fact it's imagined not be
the products of merely previous human
minds,
but they may be the products of
omniscience and that this is where the
respect accorded to religious tradition
is totally unlike the respect we would
accord to anything else.
Mythology,
literature,
past science,
past philosophy.
I mean people can read Plato and
aristotle for their entire lives without
ever,
without ever being fully captured by the
kind of dogmatism that,
that every religion demands that you be
captured.
If you're really going to be an
adherence.
I say that's actually an archetypal
truth.
You know the idea that the pathological
tradition stands in the way of update.
That's an archetypal truth.
I mean,
one of the reasons why in creation
myths,
one of the variants of a creation myth
is that the hero has to slay a
tyrannical giant in order to make it
make the world out of his pieces and
it's a metaphorical restatement of the
idea that tradition can become hidebound
and when it becomes hidebound and too
rigid that it interferes with current
adaptation.
But the problem is,
and this is,
I think this is something we really need
to hash out.
The problem is the problem that you're
describing is the problem of a priori
structure.
Now,
some of that's textual,
but some of it isn't textual.
Some of it resides in us as our psyche
in so far say
no problem.
I'm I'm describing here is that we have
two categories of,
of books in this case,
right?
We have those written by people like
ourselves just endlessly open for
criticism and and conjecture and those
written by invisible omniscient.
But I would presume that if these
religious systems weren't codafide in
books,
if they were still just enacted or
dramatized,
you'd have the same objection.
It's not the fact that they're in books
that's relevant,
but it is the dogmatism is the fact that
we can't.
We can't jettison bad part.
Okay.
It's the dogmatism.
So to me that's the same as the problem
of structure.
Now here,
here's the.
Here's the problem.
I think with the way that your argument
is laid out,
and I'm not saying it's wrong,
it seems to me that this is a place
where it needs to be developed because I
see that the attempt that you make to
derive the value from the world of facts
as as justifiable given what it is that
you're attempting to do,
which in principle is to make the world
a better place.
But there's a massive gap in there.
It's like how do you do it?
Because the objection that you place on
my,
my reasoning,
let's say,
which is.
Well,
the problem with these texts is that
there's an infinite number of
interpretations and which of them can
you.
How can you determine which of those is
canonically correct is exactly and
precisely the same criticism that can be
levied against your attempt to extract
the world of value from the domain of
facts.
It's the same.
It's not an infinite number of
interpretations in either case,
but I allow for enough to infinite.
So that might be.
I mean that's why the moral landscape
for me is a landscape of peaks and
valleys and so,
you know,
I am totally open to the possibility in
fact certainty that there are different
ways for similar minds and certainly
different ways for different minds to be
constellated so that they have
equivalent but irreconcilable peaks on
the landscape.
So you,
there's,
there's a lot of wellbeing over here and
there's a valley in between.
And so it's,
it's a kind of moral relativism.
It's kind of like,
you know,
this is,
this is great and this is great,
but these are irreconcilable.
Well,
I'd like to see that made more concrete
and I need to know how that fits in with
your conception because one of the
claims that you make in the moral
landscape is that the distinction
between the bad life and the good life
is normally it's like it's a factual
distinction.
Yes,
it's universally,
universally apprehensible and true.
It's your.
I think it's your fundamental axiomatic
claim and I don't see how that's
commensurate with the position that you
just put forward.
Was it?
So here's the position and you can
forget about morality as a concept for
this man.
I think the starting point is deeper
than morality.
The starting point,
and this is all,
this is our starting point,
all of us right now in the universe,
the starting point is we are conscious,
right?
We have a,
we have a circumstance that admits of
qualitative experience,
and again,
this is true.
Whatever,
however we understand consciousness,
whatever is actually happening,
they could be living in a simulation.
This could be a dream.
You could be a brain in a Vat.
A consciousness could just be the
product of neurochemistry or we could
have eternal souls running on on,
so how he is somehow integrated with the
brain.
Whatever is true,
something seems to be happening and the
Siemens can be really,
really bad or really,
really good.
We know each one of us in our lives have
experienced this range of possibility
and yes,
there are caveats here and there are
hard and painful experiences that have a
silver lining,
right?
That give you some other capacity where
you can say,
well,
you know,
that really sucked,
but I'm a better person for it.
Right?
And we can understand what it means to
be a better person for it.
In terms,
again,
of this range of experience,
which I,
you know,
I'm calling subsuming all of this,
the positive end of this as well being,
which is to say that you now I'm a
better person for it because now,
you know,
having endured that ordeal,
I am capable of much greater compassion
where I appreciate my life more.
You know,
the cancer made me a better person.
Now that I've,
I'm cured.
I value each moment of life more than I
ever did.
All of these claims are intelligible
within a context of an open ended
context of exploring this space of
possible experience.
So what I'm saying is forget about
morality.
Forget about right and wrong and good
and evil.
What is undeniable is that what we have
here is a navigation problem.
We have a,
a space of possible experience.
And again,
this is not just a human problem.
This is a problem for any possible
conscious mind.
We have a space of possible experience
in which we can navigate and we and
things can get excruciating and
pointlessly horrible where there are no
silver linings.
And we get this.
This can happen individually in some
episode of madness that never ends.
If there really is a Christian hell to
go to,
well then it can.
It's going to happen to me after I die,
right?
Given what I've said on the stage,
uh,
if,
so it matters who's right.
Obviously,
if I knew that a,
uh,
an eternity of fiery torment awaited
somebody who didn't make the right
noises about one or one faith or another
will,
then it would only be rational to make
those right noises,
right?
So it's,
it's my bet.
I'm placing a bet on certain pictures of
reality being wrong.
But the reality is,
is we're navigating in this space and
morality and ethics are the terms we use
for how we think about our behavior
affecting one another is experienced.
So if you're in a moral solitude,
if you're on a desert island or if
you're alone in the universe,
morality is not the issue you need to
worry about.
But wellbeing still is an ever present
issue.
It's possible to suffer and as possible
to experience bliss and,
and perhaps something beyond that.
And we,
the horizon in both directions is
something we will,
we'll never fully exposed,
explore,
very likely in the way we don't know how
good things can get and we don't know
how bad they can get,
but,
but that there's a spectrum here is
undeniable.
And I,
I would say that,
that my moral realism simply entails
that we acknowledged that it's possible
not to know what you're missing is
possible to be living in a way where you
are less happy than you could be and not
to know why.
Right?
And to not have the wisdom to make the
changes and that matters if anything
matters that matters and it matters to
us individually and it matters to us
collectively.
And that mattering is our,
is that subsumes everything we can
intelligibly want in this domain of
value.
And that's.
And so again,
it's,
it's the,
the,
the cash value of any value claim is in
the actual or potential change in
consciousness for some conscious system
somewhere sometime.
And that's,
that's my claim.
And that's.
Can I try to get,
would like to clarify something.
So it sounds to me,
Sam,
like you are hypothesizing that a
rationalist approach will always beat a
traditional metaphorical approach with
respect to the generation of wellbeing.
Well,
not always,
but there's so many obvious downsides to
the traditional sectarian dogmatic
approach that we should want to get out
of the religion business as fast as
possible.
Okay.
So,
okay.
But as fast as possible.
But do you mean that it has always been
true that we should always have gotten
away from it as fast as possible or do
you mean now we should get away from it
as fast as possible,
but there is a point somewhere in the
past where it might have been true that
actually the best,
the most,
the richest path to wellbeing might have
been encoded metaphorically.
Oh yeah.
That's certainly possible.
And in fact you might even say it was
likely based on the fact that we have
all of these systems still around.
We still have the systems around in part
because our,
like we still,
we still think in metaphor and we
actually can't help it because half of
our brain is oriented towards metaphor.
But
can I get you to clarify something now?
Yes.
Okay.
So you have argued,
and you've actually quite surprised me
by doing so.
You argued that the dogmatism is a bug
and not a feature.
You've argued it's a bug and a feature.
Okay.
It's a bug and a feature.
Good.
So yes,
but what I thought I heard you say was
that the resistance to update,
yes,
was a problem that effectively it was an
obstacle yet.
So his lack of resistance to update.
There's problems everywhere,
man.
Well,
there's a tension.
There is a tension.
Is tension.
Terrible.
Look at it this way.
Most new ideas are stupid and dangerous,
but most some of them are fighter as
well.
Some of them are vital,
right?
And so we have.
We're screwed both ways.
It's like,
well,
if we stay locked in our current mode of
apprehension,
all hell's gonna break loose.
If we generate a whole bunch of new
solutions,
most of them are going to be wrong and
we're going to die.
And so what we need to do is it's a
Darwinian claim in some sense,
is that despite the fact that most new
ideas are stupid and dangerous,
a subset of them are so vital that if we
don't incorporate them,
we're all going to perish.
That's the bloody existential condition
and so now and part of the issue here
and see,
I think that this is the problem is,
is that let's take the dogma idea.
Okay,
so there's the dogma incorporated in the
books,
but I'm gonna throw away the books
because the dogma was there before the
books and then the question is where it
was the dogma and the answer was the
dogma was in the cultural practices but
and in and in the agreement that people
made with regards to those cultural
practices,
but it was also part and parcel of the
Inter psychic structure that enables us
to perceive the world as such.
Now the problem is,
and I think this is the central place
where we need to flesh out these ideas,
is that you cannot view the world
without an a priori structure and that a
prior structure has a dogmatic element,
and so you can't just say,
well,
let's get rid of the dog one,
because you can't perceive the world
structure has an uninspected element.
Because if you're talking about just
perceiving the world,
yes we have.
We have perceptual structure that allows
for us to perceive the world and we know
that there are failures states,
right?
So we know,
we know for instance,
that we are,
we are,
we have evolved to perceive visual space
based on a literally neurological
expectation that light sources will be
from above.
Right.
And so we know that we can produce
visual illusions based on gaming that
expectation.
Right?
But that's not the same thing as a,
a dogma we subscribed to by some,
some subset of humanity that is
antithetical to another dogma subscribed
to by another set of humanity that has
nothing to do with underlying biology.
That's something that is changeable,
obvious.
Nobody's changeable in real time based
on just conversations like this.
Like,
you know,
we could,
I get emails from people who can point
to these,
the paragraph where they lost their
faith,
right?
Where in reading somebody's reading,
reading Richard Dawkins or newborn
hearing,
a debate between between me and some
theologian where it's just a was a
collision against rationality,
which is so useful in every other
context suddenly proves its utility in
this context where they think,
well,
okay,
clearly I know the Muslims are wrong
about the status of the Koran.
Let me,
let me take that.
That that spirit of criticism in the
internal space of my own culture and
what moves well,
a dogmatic attachment to Christianity
has to move by that same standard and
that's and and it's possible to do that
and that's not a matter of getting into
the brain and changing your perceptual
apparatus.
That has.
Well the distinction between different
levels of what would you call it,
structure related processing in the
brain and the relationship to the
underlying biology isn't clear.
Like it isn't clear when that's
biological and when is it,
when it isn't.
So you know,
your,
your comments about our a priori
perceptual structures not withstanding,
there's no clear line between what
constitutes and instantiated accurate
biological perception and something that
shades more into a cultural.
A presupposition,
so it's a.
it's a gray area.
Now here,
let me ask you a question.
So this is one of the things I've been
thinking about.
So this is.
This is designed to point out
difference.
I'm not making the claim that the idea
that we should ground values in fact is
wrong.
I'm not going to make that claim,
although we think it's way more
complicated than we've opened up so far,
but I would say is I can relatively
easily demonstrate a situation in which
you cannot find the value from the fact.
Let's say you own an antique,
it's valuable and you think I'm going to
take this antique apart and I'm going to
find out where the value is.
Good luck.
It's not valuable in that sense where
I'll.
Wait a sec,
wait a sec.
So we need to know.
So that's right.
It's not valuable in that sense because
the value of the antique is a social
agreement about its position in a
hierarchy.
It has nothing to do with the material
substrate at the end.
Yeah,
but it's not
claim already that you can derive value
from fat.
It's like,
then what are you willing to.
These are facts about again,
so there are facts about the facts exist
in intersubjective space.
Right?
So if I,
if I tell you,
well,
this glass,
this isn't just an ordinary glass.
I know it looks just like that one,
but this is the glass that Elton John
Drank from his last concert here.
Right?
So what do you want to pay me for it?
Right.
It could be that,
you know,
you're just the biggest Elton John Fan
ever and it's worth quite a lot to you
now.
That is,
it's a kind of evidence is not value
intrinsic to the glass,
but it is,
it is,
it is a.
where's the value located?
Was,
is a measure in the change.
This provokes in your experience,
right?
There's the idea.
I mean we value ideas as much as
anything else and that's,
that's hence the,
the mad work done by religion,
right?
I mean because it's not.
These aren't facts on the ground.
These are ideas that rural people's
lives.
People spend their whole life afraid of.
Hell,
okay.
It seems to meet that it's easier in
some sense rather than to relate the
value of that,
and I love the Elton John's class
example to use Elvis Presley is here.
I will.
I will tell you,
it's like where in the guitar is the
fact that it's Elvis Presley's and
guitar,
while it's nowhere in the guitar.
Well,
what is it in?
Where is it that,
and the answer is it's in the dominance
hierarchy values that's been socially
constructed around the guitar.
It's located at an interpersonal space
and that that location,
so value is located in interpersonal
space and if you want to say,
well,
that's also a fact.
It's like,
okay,
but
we're starting to stretch the beliefs
and desires and conscious dates of all
the people involved.
That's the only place where it exists.
That's the only fair enough with the
idea of Elvis' guitar can show up.
Well,
I'm trying to figure out then you see,
because what seems to me to be happening
at least in part is that we can stretch
the the domain of what constitutes of
facts so that the domain of fact starts
to incorporate the domain of values,
but we do that with some doing some
damage to the domain of fact.
No,
no,
no.
Hang on.
Don't,
don't say,
don't just say no,
I'll more.
This is really complicated because you
see,
part of what the postmodernists have
done is they've pushed away the domain
of facts entirely and they say,
well,
the only thing is is that the only thing
that actually exists is that this domain
of intersubjective agreement and
no.
Yeah,
you and I are on the same page with
respect to postmodern.
Right?
But,
but,
but you have to give,
but you have to give them.
You have to give the devil his due as
well.
They're pointed out something and what
they pointed out is that it's not so
easy to localize the structure that
attributes to fax their value.
It's not a simple thing that we were
way.
Yes.
You would surely agree that if we had
Elvis Presley's guitar,
that that guitar would have a material
impact on people.
We could tell them this is Elvis
Presley's guitar.
Some fraction of them would disbelieve
it.
Somebody might be able to establish it
based on a picture or something like
that,
and the point is it would have a value
that would alter the behavior of people
with respect to that object in a
material way.
Yes,
it would alter the behavior of the p
values manifest in physical space.
Which part of it?
The detective.
We could figure out what the value of
this guitar is based on some
intersection.
Sure.
We can take a behaviorist approach and
we could see how much work people were
willing to do to contact.
We can scan their brains and see what we
can do that well.
Well,
clearly I ran it evolved.
Hypothetically.
We can do it,
but practically we're not so good
because the MRI data,
generally speaking is junk.
Well,
the way we can table that,
that's controversial statement in Mri
circles.
It's fair enough.
I don't think we need it.
We need it,
but we go with that.
A market will establish the brain.
The brain as yet incompletely understood
is surely involved in the value of this
object.
Right?
And so if I take,
if I tell you that this is,
and again we can take it out of
intersubjective space because it
couldn't you,
you could be in a value solitude with
respect to any given object,
so it could just be,
you could have a sentimental attachment
to your watch that's worth exactly $25
because that's what you paid for it,
but this is the watch that you know,
this is your first watch or whatever it
is and you wouldn't sell it for any
amount of money.
That's a measure of your but behavioral
measure of how much you value it.
And if I told you,
oh well,
you know,
sorry,
I brought your watch and lost it.
What the cascade of negative effects
that I see on your face as correlated
with something that's happening in your
head and the brain is involved.
Right?
So that the quality of that picture
basically state is devalued.
Tell us that there'd be a socio cultural
agreement as to the value of whatever
this entity is and that would find it's
mirroring the brain and that's a
noncontroversial stated,
Ecos,
all socio cultural phenomena that are
experienced find a reflection of the
brain.
The fact that you can say that that's
reflected in the brain.
Yeah.
Continually run into with religion is
that there you have a domain of so
called sacred values where people who
are otherwise rational ceased to be
rational actors,
so the reason why Israel and the
Israelis and the Palestinians can't
negotiate as though their problems could
be solved by a real estate transaction
is because they have irrational and
irreconcilable claims upon land and
building.
Do you think there are any more
irrational than the claim that that
class is worth something when no one
knows that it's like that,
but I'm not irrational by your own
definition.
You just said that that was actually
constituted a fact.
It's a fact about people,
right?
So this is okay.
Just be a little careful here because it
gets confusing.
The there are.
We can make objective claims about
subjective experience,
right?
It's not as,
it's there are,
we use this word objective and
subjective in,
in different ways.
We use it in an epistemological ways and
ontological ways,
and give me just one sec to make sure
I'm on the same,
uh,
by.
I can illustrate it by way of example.
If I say no,
that's just your subjective opinion,
right?
I'm saying I'm denigrating.
I'm saying that this is an expression of
your bias.
This is this,
this is true for you,
but it's not true out in the world,
right?
That's one way I can use the,
the subjective objective distinction,
and that's an epistomological way.
Like you're,
you're,
you're ruled by bias.
You're not thinking straight.
You know,
I don't have to take your opinion
seriously.
That's subjective.
I'm worried about objective facts,
but people get confused.
They think that objective facts only
means the material world.
And what's the,
what's really in this glass as a
material object.
No,
we can be much more objective than that.
We can,
we can make objective claims about the
subjective experience of,
of people like ourselves.
I can,
I can make an infinite number of
objective claims about the experience
of.
This is the example I always use,
but I just happen to love it.
What,
what was jfk thinking the moment he got
shot right there.
That's it.
We don't know that we'll never get the
data right.
So the,
the,
the truth or falseness of,
of what I'm about to say can't be
predicated on actually getting access to
the data because because he's not around
and his brain's not around to scan.
Uh,
so,
but we,
you and I both know an infinite number
of things he wasn't thinking about.
We can make an objective claim about his
subjectivity.
I know he wasn't thinking,
well,
I hope Jordan Peterson has Sam Harris'
work it out on stage that night and an
infinite number of things like that.
He was thinking something.
He was experiencing something but we
don't know what it is that.
So I saw what I'm talking about.
This domain of value.
I'm saying that it exists in the this
landscape of actual impossible conscious
experience for human beings and any
other system like us,
they can experience this range of
suffering and happen.
Well.
So partly
what I'm trying to do is to actually
determine what that structure is.
So in our case it's certainly connected
to the evolved structure of our brain by
everything else.
They want to go way deeper into to the
idea then it's connected with brain
states because it's.
Yes,
it's definitely connected with brain
states.
The question is at least in part how and
what does that mean?
And I think that the neuroscience has
progressed far enough so that we can do
quite a good job of this.
And so what I want to return to one
thing,
and maybe I'll outline a little bit of
this and when you talked about the
Israeli Palestinian conflict,
you said that that was irrational.
And so look,
you know,
fair enough,
people have been locked with their hands
around each other's necks there for 3000
years.
But there's a problem there and the
problem is that people are looking at
the landscape from a contextualized
perspective,
right?
It's not just a piece of land,
it's their piece of land.
It's like your house or your favorite
shirt.
It's like,
what?
You say,
well,
I have a favorite shirt.
It's like,
well,
there's nothing inherent in the shirt
that makes it your favorite.
No,
it's a subjective judgment.
It's like,
well then is that a fact?
Well,
yes,
it's a fact.
It's a fact about subjective judgment.
It's okay.
While the Israeli claim on the land and
the Palestinian claim on the land is a
subjective judgment that
it's like,
so how is it saving it?
Because it is the.
The true analogy here.
The complete analogy is rather like
we're about to fight over Elton John's
glass and Elton John was never here.
Right?
Not saying it clearly still matters to
us.
In our misapprehension of our situation,
we still really care.
And these are.
These are objectively true claims about
the level at which we value things and
hence the impasse.
But it matters if it's counter
productively dismissive,
like you could say,
well,
when you look at this specific claim,
there's really not.
Look you took,
you took the contextual interpretation
to its absolute extreme.
You said,
well there's multiple reasons why
different people who occupied the same
piece of land are going to feel about it
in different ways.
Sure.
Okay.
And those reasons are amenable to some
kind of rational compromise actually
studies on this.
I mean there's studies done by people
who,
when you say this rewrap it,
you say the word rational in that
context,
you're using it as a black box that
contains the concept proper way of
thinking about it.
It's like it's not so obvious in most
situations what the rational approach
is.
I always have an obvious one here and
that's that whatever the Christians and
the Muslims and the Jews think they're
getting from their attachment to their
dogmatic and irreconcilable and
religious worldviews can be gotten just
as well by a deeper understanding of
the,
of our universal and non culturally
bound capacity for ethical experience,
spiritual experience,
community building.
And we can.
What's that?
We can touch that specs without.
It's almost like the status quo is,
it's almost like your content to live in
a world or your at least your content,
not to judge too harshly a world where
fans of rival soccer teams or baseball
teams regularly kill one another over
their fandom.
Right?
Like,
oh,
like what if that were the status quo?
So He's been this way for thousands of
years.
There must be a reason for it,
but I really like sports.
I'm not trying to justify the Israeli
Palestinian conflict.
No,
but I'm saying that too quick to judge
the sanctity of their,
of their differences of opinion.
Okay,
but wait a minute,
Sam,
there you made a claim.
Your claim was that if the Christians
and the Jews and the Muslims would just
stop their stupidity and adopt this
universal ethic,
then everything would be okay.
It's like,
okay,
what's the basis for the universal ethic
like that sets.
That's the truth isn't.
But that's an interesting problem for
philosophers and for scientists.
That's not actually where the rubber
meets the road for people living their
lives.
Well,
I mean,
is this analogous to me,
the difference between the band?
I really care about all of this and I
and my job as a,
as a philosophy,
as a moral philosopher in that case is
to make the best case I can for these
ideas,
but the truth is it is analogous to when
when you get into a debate with a
Christian fundamentalists in the states,
very often this per this person will
pretend to care about cosmology as or
evolution as though it's the most
important thing in the world as though
you can't get out of bed in the morning
and figure out how to treat your friends
and family well unless you figure out
what happened before the Big Bang,
right?
No one really lives their lives that way
and yet we have convinced ourselves that
this is a sensible way of talking about
the conflict between religion and
science.
I think you have arrived at the core of
your conflict right here,
and I actually hear you both loud and
clear.
Your point is that if the people faced
with the question where to start with a
fresh sheet of paper,
look at the Middle East,
they could arrive at a compromise that
they as individuals might find a put
them way ahead and is more profitable
than the situation that they are
continually finding themselves and that
might be the case.
On the other hand,
the reason that they don't is that
historically those who have have been
out competed by those who haven't,
so the point is the universe and the
fact that it refuses to solve that
conflict is telling us that there is
some reason that people who take that
prospect seriously are not actually
correct in some at least metaphorical.
So in other words,
what is it to have a sentimental
attachment to some piece of territory
somewhere that sounds completely
irrational.
On the other hand,
that sentimental attachment may result
in you continuing for 500 or a thousand
or 2000 years.
Whereas if you surrendered it because it
was irrational,
you might go extinct.
Now,
should you care that your lineage is
going to go extinct?
Maybe,
arguably not.
On the other hand,
it's hard to imagine that what you're
saying is so thoroughly grounded that it
can justify causing people to alter
their perspective on value in such a way
that it might actually drive them
extinct.
It's not clear that that's good.
Clearly secularism made.
You were talking about the fringe here.
We're talking about that when you're
talking about this case,
the Israeli settlers and the Palestinian
terrorists,
right?
Like that is that is it.
We should all breathe a sigh of relief
that that doesn't,
that,
that kind of passion,
that attachment to land doesn't
characterize most of humanity if you're
trying to defend your house.
So,
but,
but that's.
Can I kind of different topic on Jordan,
because I think this is.
This is where,
this is where the crux of it is.
If,
if we follow the idea that this is
actually some,
that the seemingly sentimental and
irrational attachment to the piece of
land is some sort of Meta rationality,
which sounds like your perspective than
we are now confronted with the question
of,
all right,
if it is an evolved kind of a
rationality that is being manifest in
stories that cause people to behave in
ways that Sam sees as clearly
irrational,
then we are stuck with the naturalistic
fallacy,
which is to say so for those who don't
know,
the naturalistic fallacy says that just
because something is doesn't mean it
ought,
right?
The fact that selection favors something
doesn't make it good and the aztecs
sacrificed their enemies.
It is good for continuing as Technis,
but it may not be good in some absolute
moral sense.
So here's the question for you.
You're arguing for an I think an
evolutionarily very viable explanation
for religious belief and dogma,
but aren't you stuck with the downside
of it?
Where much of what is encoded in that
way may actually be abhorrent,
morally unconscious?
Absolutely.
Okay,
so what are you doing about it?
What do we do about what this is?
This is exactly how a sorting algorithm.
Yes.
What is it?
Trying to get to it.
Okay.
Okay,
so this is actually why I asked Sam this
question.
It wasn't.
It wasn't an attack.
It's like,
okay,
so look,
people have these belief systems,
Christian Muslim,
Jew will say for that,
and you're saying abandoned analysts,
let's say two to and move towards this
transcendent rationality.
It's like,
okay,
two problems.
It's not so easy to abandon the belief
system because you ended up in the
morally relativist nihilist pit problem.
One doesn't have to tend to and so
they don't have to claim that.
We would be.
We'd have to find out whether that is
true.
There's a lot of evidence against that.
Well,
there's plenty of evidence for it too,
but it's beside the point to some degree
because that isn't.
That isn't something that I want to
quibble about.
The perhaps there are trends.
There are transitional paths and
sometimes people find a collapse of
their faith.
Actually freeing.
It's certainly the case that many of the
people who are are are happy about what
you're doing have found exactly that in
what you've been saying and more power
to you and so I'm not willing to dispute
that,
but what you said was,
okay,
here's these belief systems that are
ancient and complex and we can step
outside of the men.
There's this transcendent rationality
that we could all aspire to that would
solve the problems.
It's like,
okay,
what is it?
Well,
what is it exactly?
It is at a minimum to value all of the
variables that conspire to make the one
life.
We know we have key value.
All those variables.
Well,
no,
we were doing it right.
We do it every day in how we organize
ourselves.
Why an a priori framework to the
variables to say,
to reduce them to a tiny subset that we
can manage and it's the nature of that.
A priority framework that we haven't
been able to have a discussion about.
We have an API framework that narrows
our perception to almost nothing.
It's built into us.
It's partly socially constructed.
It has a deep neurological substrate and
we actually understand how it emerges to
a large degree and the thing is is that
I don't
think that's actually our difference.
So this is a priority for framework,
operates in many different spaces,
which again,
we can't necessarily analyze,
but it makes it no less true.
So if you,
if you put your hand on a hot stove,
you will immediately feel a good,
a very good reason.
In fact,
in unarguably good reason to remove it.
Right?
And that's,
it doesn't require a moral philosophy to
get you there.
You don't need a,
you don't need to inspect your a priori
framework.
You just have to feel,
Holy Shit,
this is the worst thing I've ever felt.
Right?
And there's so many moments like that in
life that we dimly under that we
understand that sometimes to rescue your
child from a fire.
Well,
exactly.
Then you have,
you have some other goal,
right?
Cause you to brave that,
that suffering,
right?
And,
but again,
trying to rescue your child from a fire
is pretty close to as the hot stove in
not needing to be analyzed.
Right?
The imperative to rescue your it,
it becomes harder when you have to
rescue someone else's child from a fire
and you're and you're worried about
orphan in your child who's standing next
to you on the sidewalk,
right?
Then we get into the domain of moral
philosophy and then you can say,
well,
what do what?
How much do each of us?
Oh,
the children of other people,
right?
How much did I risk my life and risk
orphaning my child to rescue your child?
That's when things get interesting in a
philosophy seminar and that's where
people begin to hesitate.
People begin to w we we are biased
toward protecting,
protecting our kin,
protecting our friends,
and only then do we begin to extend the
circle and again and again,
moral,
but it's not a mystery where we w,
W,
we want to go here.
We want to extend the circle more and
more and build institutions and
societies that,
that,
that implement our best selves at our
best moments.
More and more.
It makes it more effortless to be good
in the defendant.
Take your example seriously here for a
sec.
Yeah.
Alright,
so you are built to be more likely to
rescue your own child in someone else's
child from a fire we in society,
might like for the minimum number of
children to die in fires as possible,
which gets you to sideline that
consideration in favor of is there a
child,
uh,
who,
who's faced with a fire,
who I'm,
who I might rescue religions,
do exactly this restructuring of values
because they say something like,
actually your goodness in risking your
own life to save that other child from a
fire is observed and it is,
it is calculated and you will be
rewarded for it in some way.
That's,
that's one possible benefit of some
religions.
Right?
Good.
And okay,
so he put that on the balance.
But I have a lot to put on the other
side of the boundary.
Do I know you list?
I want to,
I,
which that's what I'm trying to point
out to Jordan here,
which he actually
knowledges,
which is that he's got a big stack of
good things that come from this
heuristic,
but
he's also acknowledging,
get this.
This is our core of disagreement here,
which is however you want to,
however the balance is going to swing.
The difference between us here is that I
think we read the utility of real,
of,
of anything,
but in this case,
religious thinking as evidence of you,
you read it as evidence of something
perhaps is literally true inevitability,
and I view that as a kind of version of
either genetic or naturalistic fallacy
that is just telling you the weather,
whether that's it's,
it's useful.
Now here for us,
it doesn't,
doesn't argue that it's the best way of
getting those good things.
I mean,
my argument here is that religion gives
people bad reasons to be good.
We're good reasons are available.
So that's a problem,
right?
Because good real good reasons.
Scale better than bad reasons,
and I think we can under even if you
take the case where religion is clearly
useful,
Leah,
in a life saving utterly benign way,
uh,
in,
in virtually all of those cases,
I think I can,
I can get you there by some other way
without the downside or if not,
that's just one of those cases where
yes,
the fiction was more useful than any
possible.
Distinguish a religious system from an
eight perceptual
structure.
Well,
if you can convert to it or away from it
in a single conversation,
I would say if it doesn't go very deep,
well you're,
you're only.
I would say that for much of that,
you're only converting at a very
superficial level.
Well,
no converting at the level of conscious
apprehension and most of your cognition
is done through unconscious process.
It's just a fact about us that most of
people's religious attachment is born of
having it drummed into them by their
parents.
Right?
If I made it,
but the truth,
they don't know their parents and their
parents' parents and their parents
aren't exactly.
But if we did the same thing with Batman
and Spiderman,
they would have the same effect,
right?
Like if,
if you relentlessly told children,
right?
I mean,
I've,
I've got two little girls who were
dressed up like bankroll right now.
They love batgirl.
There's nothing.
I don't have to do anything to make them
more enthusiastic about superheroes
apart from just showing them the
pictures of superheroes,
right?
If I told them,
in addition to how,
look how fun this is to dress up like
batgirl.
In addition,
you're going to burn in hell for
eternity.
If you lose your emotional attachment to
batgirl even for a minute,
right?
Well then it's going to be bad girl for
the rest of their lives,
especially if the entire culture is,
is doing likewise.
And again.
Well,
as Brett pointed out already,
a bad tool is better than no tool at
all.
And if batgirl is the closest
approximation to a divine sacred that
you can conjure up at beats the hell out
of none at all.
And if bad girl didn't partake of
certain archetypal structures,
no one would give a damn about you
after.
Okay,
I'm going to fight a minute,
Batman.
I'm going to spare you
play a role in the car because
accidental,
not accidental,
that superhero stories have a structure
and to say that,
well,
Batman and Spiderman are obvious
fictions and we could use
picking the wrong end.
You're taking the wrong into this.
I'm not.
I'm not minimizing the power of stories,
right?
I'm saying we can understand their power
without recourse to believing things we
shouldn't believe now and
21st century,
we still need an answer to the question
about what it is that's this
transcendent,
transcendental rational structure
without an an a priori don't want,
because I don't see it.
Again,
we.
We touched on this a little bit last
night in that I freely admitted that in
every domain of human inquiry,
no matter how the most hard headed,
so mathematics,
logic,
physics,
at some point we have to pull ourselves
up by our bootstraps.
At some point we make a move that is not
self justifying and is not justified by
any other move that's more rudimentary,
right?
That's a statement of faith that callow
use of the term faith.
Same precise definition of an axiom,
my faith,
my faith.
That two plus two makes four.
That's not what?
No,
it didn't.
No.
Is My intuition that this is a valid and
replicable and generalizeable principle,
right?
Neither your statement that that's a
useful claim is a statement of faith.
But neither of those two were statements
of faith.
No,
it was their statements.
Tuition.
None of those.
These are intuitions.
These are because and their intuitions
that can run a foul of other discoveries
and other intuitions as you know.
Which.
Well,
if mathematical facts or intuitions then
what are we doing with?
Take a tape.
So we've arrived.
No,
no,
no.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
We have to decide.
The super important that we don't lose
it.
Okay.
So we,
for what 2000 years people have been
studying geometry and had a very well
worked out set of mathematical
intuitions with respect to Euclidean
space,
you know,
flat geometry and then some brilliant
guy.
You know,
Remonde might've been the first said,
well they actually,
you can curve space.
I can bend this triangle and all of a
sudden it has more than 180 degrees.
Right?
That's an intuition that people tuned up
pretty quickly,
but all of humanity was blind to it for
the longest time.
Right?
These are what I mean by intuition is
it's the thing you're using to
understand something that you.
You are not in a position to analyze.
Now that's,
but that's not faith of the sort which
is.
Listen,
I know the Bible was dictated by the
creator of the universe.
I know Jesus was his son.
I know he rose from the dead.
I know he'll be coming back
and a thousand other propositional claim
statement.
It's a highly valuable.
If it's a statement of faith and it's in
a value domain,
how is it drivable from fact?
So we've arrived at the point where we
have to decide whether to go to q and a
or to continue the discussion.
While you all are thinking about that,
I would like to level the challenge to
each of you and then I will pull the
audience and see what they think about q
and a.
okay?
Okay.
So Jordan is arguing to you that you
cannot ground the values that would
undergird the modality of increasing
wellbeing in anything factual and you
are arguing in response to that.
Not Without an intermediary.
Let me just argue in a whole lot of
sense.
Not Without an intermediary struck.
What I've heard you argue is something
that I,
that I agree
with,
which is that you can ground many things
in a nearly,
um,
objective observation of the universe,
but it doesn't say anything about the
value part of the equation.
And in fact,
I think having thought about the
question from an evolutionary point of
view,
that in order to do what you're talking
about,
to increase wellbeing,
you are going to have to accept that.
That is going to leave you with an
arbitrary grounding.
There is no absolute grounding for it.
And you're going to have to just simply
accept that it's going to you arbitrary
that you are in fact going to have to do
inconsistent things like decide to honor
the love of a mother for her child and
dishonor the love of country that causes
one population to gas another
population.
That's inconsistent and then will need
to embrace that in kind of inconsistent.
I've it.
It's just a different.
I don't think we even have the grounding
problem.
I think it's a pseudo problem.
I think what you just said,
we have to put your stuff in somewhere.
We have a navigate.
The way it's grounded is the
acknowledgement that what we have is ms
dot.
It's analogous to what people do with
the notion of of meaning in life like
what's the meaning of life?
How do you find meaning in life?
What?
What's the purpose of life?
These are bad questions.
These are questions that when you pose
them,
they seem to demand.
They suggest a space in which an answer
must be put,
but it's.
It's just you put an answer.
They'll.
People should work towards the good.
Yes,
there's a different.
There's a different way of framing it,
which is what we have.
Here is an opportunity.
It's not about.
It's not a matter of meaning.
It's not a matter of purpose and it's
not a matter of grounding.
It's a matter of we are in a
circumstance where that where we have
consciousness and its contents in every
moment and all of this is that the light
the lights are on and they're on for
reasons that we dimly understand right
there.
These are the reasons that are
biological in our case,
but perhaps at bottom there just based
on information processing and their
platform independent and then we would
build machines for whom the life of the
light is actually on or not.
Right.
This is,
it remains to be seen whether we could
actually build in our computers,
conscious minds that can thrive or
suffer,
right,
and that the difference matters,
but we're in a circumstance where we are
trying to understand how conscious
consciousness and it states arises,
but one thing that is undeniable is that
the lights are on and being on.
They reveal a spectrum of experience
that w,
w,
W,
which has one end that we the,
the,
the worse it gets,
the more compelling it is to move away
from it.
That reading that's meaning,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So and then and all of our meaning talk
and value talk relates to navigating in
this space.
So there's,
there's one end of it where things get
needlessly horrible without a silver
lining and there's another end where it
gets better and better and non zero sum
that all boats are rising with the same
tide and the Israelis and the
Palestinians,
the landscape cable and good.
So okay.
So these are compelling ways to talk
about this space of,
of navigation.
What do you do?
So
when you accept your space of navigation
and there's a conflict between wellbeing
for the living population,
earth versus wellbeing over the maximum
populations that could possibly live
into the future when there's a big
conflict between how much wellbeing
we're going to feel now versus how much
wellbeing future human beings will get
to feel.
Yeah.
Well that,
that those are legitimate ethical
problems which we,
I think we often live in the space where
we know there's a right answer,
that we are too selfish to fulfill or
too short sided to fulfill.
Like so I know there are things I do
every day that not only will other
people as yet unborn,
wish I hadn't done,
I might wake up tomorrow wishing I
hadn't done those things right,
so like I'm a,
I'm a bad friend to my future self in
some respect to say nothing of the rest
of humanity so we can be so we can have
failures,
we can have weakness of will,
we can have failures that we can just be
wrong about certain things,
but it's nowhere written that is easy to
be a good person.
Right?
In that case,
it's not even clear what good means is
clear.
I'm saying cases really knows the
answer.
It might be hard to be motivated by that
knowledge and that because we're not a
unity,
right?
I mean,
part of,
part of what wisdom is morally is an
ability to be,
to live integrated enough with your own,
you know,
better self.
We have the advice you would give to a
friend of this.
This just falls right out of your work
as well as live as though,
but basically treat yourself the way you
would treat.
I think this is your line,
so you know someone you you're you're
responsible for,
or there's somebody,
a friend of yours,
right.
If you can,
if you can do that,
you're already ahead of who most people
are most of the time,
but there's no.
There's no reason to say that because
it's difficult or because sometimes
we're looking through a glass darkly and
can't figure out what the answer is.
The answer doesn't exist or there is no
right one.
Okay.
Now let me try with you.
Yeah,
so Jordan,
you have argued for a and evolved
framework of religious belief in which
there are elements that are morally
defensible,
that will be carried through time.
There are elements that are morally
reprehensible that will be carried
through time by virtue of the fact that
they are effective and you have argued
that these things,
because they have withstood the test of
time,
have some kind of value,
which is not necessarily something that
we should honor,
but some large fraction of it must be,
but that would seem to suggest that the
degree to which these belief structures
has value is contingent on the degree to
which the environment in which we
attempt to deploy these structures
matches the environment in which they
evolved.
Absolutely.
Now,
I would argue that no population of
humans has lived farther from its
ancestral environment,
and we do think that's a fallacy.
You think so because,
well,
it isn't.
It isn't.
And look,
I think that's an absolutely valid
point.
Okay,
so,
so this gets esoteric relatively
rapidly,
but the question is,
let's say at the highest levels of
adaptation,
we're adapted to the things that last
the longest periods of time.
Those are the most permanent things.
Now the question is what are those most
permanent things?
And you know,
one answer would be the fundamental
material substrate of the world,
and that's true.
I'm going to leave that be like we were
evolved to deal with gravity.
Okay?
But there are other elements that are
higher order abstractions in some sense
that are also apparently hyperreal.
So for example,
there's.
There's a problem that we have a
bifurcated,
right?
The question is,
well,
why did we have a bifurcated brain?
And the answer seemed to not just us.
Animals to Nasser seems to be,
well,
there's two necessary ways of looking at
the world and they have to be in
conflict to some degree in order to work
properly.
The right hemisphere and the left
hemisphere,
the right hemisphere mode is a lot more
metaphorical than the left hemisphere.
The right hemisphere is the hemisphere
that seems to deal with exceptions to
the rule,
and it seems to deal with the exceptions
to the rule by men,
by treating them,
by aggregating them,
and then trying to recognize patterns
that unite them as a corrective to the
totalitarian system in some sense that
the left hemisphere imposes.
You could say that the right and the
left are adapted for something like
explored territory for the left and
unexplored territory for the right.
I've characterized that is order versus
chaos and I think the religious
landscape is good versus evil to Sam's
point that we should strive for a good
life on a landscape of chaos versus
order,
and I think that landscape is permanent.
Now I know we moved from our African
ancestral homeland,
but these,
this underlying abstraction,
this underlying,
this underlying reality is so profound
that it it,
it maintains its validity across all
sets of potential environmental
transformations.
Okay?
Okay.
Can I just jump in here because here's
why.
Just to see is on one piece you put in
play there.
Here's why good and evil can't be
permanent in the usual sense.
Certainly not in the Christian Judeo
Christian sense.
One is the Judeo Christian notion of
good and evil doesn't even map onto to
eastern religion.
You made a good evil versus good claimed
in the moral but it,
but it's also in an eastern context and
a Buddhist or Hindu context.
The evil isn't really evil.
It's just ignorance.
Now you might dispute that you might
say,
well that's not really.
They haven't met a sufficiently evil
person to if they can think that,
but the reality is that billions of
people who have a different rubric under
wisdom make the case,
but let's let.
Let me add another another piece here.
We're just going to ask them,
okay,
we need.
You guys need to go guys want this to
continue?
Or do you want q and a to begin?
I don't know which one you're fearing
for.
Give them.
Give them
first group is the group that wants this
conversation to continue.
Now the group that would prefer
q and a,
it was the former.
What?
What's disturbing is that many of the
same people were laughing.
Proves what Jordan was saying about the
two hemispheres,
the brain metaphor.
So I mean it seems to me,
and again,
correct me if I'm wrong,
is that you made an absolute world claim
in the moral landscape and that's what
grounds here argument
these because it'll be interesting if
it's not totally on point.
The reason why evil is susceptible to
total deflation is if you agree with me,
evil is a category of human misbehavior,
human intention that we don't understand
significantly at the level of the brain,
but if we did understand it totally at
the level of the brain than every evil
person we had in the doc at trial would
be just like Charles Whitman with his
brain tumor after he shot up everyone at
the University of Texas.
Right?
So like he,
he is,
he's the prototypically evil mass
murder,
but he's complaining about this change
that overcame his personality and he
thinks it would be good.
A good idea that if after the cops kill
me,
you autopsy my brain because I don't
know why I'm doing any of this.
Right.
And Lo and behold,
he had a glioblastoma pressing on his
amygdala and all of a sudden it made
sense of his behavior in a way that a
full understanding of psychopathy or
every other variant of human evil would
make sense of it in a way that would be
deflationary ethically.
And then you would look at.
So then you look at someone like Saddam
Hussein or the worst evil person you
could imagine,
and you would say,
well,
he's actually unlucky you know there,
but for the grace of biology,
go on.
Because if I had that brain,
if I had those jeans,
if I had those influences that gave me
those synapses,
I would be just like him.
Now if you think there's some other
element that gives us free will and now
then,
then you and I are disagree that that's
a factual claim.
That's at variance with mind.
But,
but if we are just on some level now a
malfunctioning biological systems when
we're being evil than a complete
understanding of evil would cancel that
category.
Can you define evil?
So we know what you're talking about.
Well just take,
take the just the worst people who have
statistically victimized the most people
and those are the evil,
evil people.
So when you say,
so I think this is actually really
important.
So I think actual evil of that kind is
pretty darn rare.
And there's a lot of badness that email
from one of the most troubling thing or
all the good people doing evil because
they're ruled by bad ideas,
but that I think is more consequential
than we actually.
We introduced a whole set of other
things here in the last little round
with freewill and evil,
but,
but just to
want to make it clear why I went there,
you were saying this is,
this is,
I forgot the word.
You used inevitable or ineluctable
Lloyd's permit applications that this
category is permanent.
And I'm saying that I don't think but
equal in that sense as a permanent
category for us.
They do weights more information and
insight.
Okay,
we're going to distinguish for a minute.
Good versus evil and good versus bad.
Just for the sake of conceptual clarity
in the moral landscape,
you make a fundamental axiomatic plane,
looks like a moral claim.
Maybe it's claim of fact.
And the claim is there are bad lives and
good lives.
Sure.
And the claim you make is that,
that's universally true.
It's true for the requisite lines,
Buddhist,
Hindu,
it doesn't matter.
Okay,
but evil,
so yes,
I'm not.
I'm not telling you that you should
purge the word evil from your your
vocabulary.
I use the word all the time and I think
it's useful to motivating word.
I'm just saying that it's there.
We can understand this continuum of good
and bad or positive and negative in ways
that don't use the.
The.
Certainly don't use the Judeo Christian
framework for value in these things
because if you.
If you take the Buddhist framework and
map it onto this,
this continuum,
you don't get good and evil.
You get essentially wisdom and ignorance
in an evil is ignorance of all the
wellbeing you would you and others would
experience if you behaved another way.
Right?
That's the Buddhist game and we're even
within Hinduism and they get this
connects to your.
Your,
your love of stories.
You take the,
the,
the Hindu texts.
The Ramayana,
which is just a foundation,
is doing the work that the Bible is
doing for Jews and Christians in that.
The worst guy in the Ramayana,
the 10 headed Demon Rovena,
the prototypically evil person is at
bottom.
Really not a bad guy.
He's a great sage who is just in a bad
mood essentially.
Right?
He was was.
He was obscured by ignorance and so it
isn't the Buddhist cannon,
the Buddhist,
the Buddha made say a serial killer who
knows wearing a garland of human fingers
around his neck,
named ongoing on Gooley Mala,
but he was just one conversation away
from being fully enlightened.
Right?
I mean,
he was like,
this is a different picture of a
possibility.
I'm not saying one is right or wrong.
Let's be agnostic about that.
I'm just.
I'm challenging your claim that there's
something so precious and useful and
durable about the Judeo Christian
I wasn't making.
I wasn't making what we're stuck with it
for all time.
You see making that claim.
I was making the claim that in the moral
landscape you laid out a distinction
between the bird life and the good life.
Forget about rutten evil,
the bad life and the good life Hell and
heaven,
bad life and the good life,
and that that distinction was not only
factual but universal
and so you the right mind so that we
could imagine a mind.
I mean,
this is an example.
I think in a right mind you we can,
we can create circumstances that seem
perverse to us that we were would recoil
from.
You could you could create a universe of
perfectly matched,
say this and masochists say right,
so you have the people who are real
sadists who in our world would be
terrible actors,
but in their world they're surrounded by
people who want to be mistreated.
Now again,
this may
real estate is you never mistreated
masochist when he asks you,
okay,
well these are not
for the human categories even exists,
but in some we undoubtedly we could
create something like an artificial
intelligence that could be google.
It could be paired this way and that
would be weird,
but on my,
in my framework,
it is a conceivable space of equivalent
wellbeing and if it's not matched at all
to our space,
right?
It's,
but it's if,
if in fact we could inspect the
conscious minds of all parties
participate in that.
It is not obviously absurd by in my view
to say that they are just as happy as we
are in this conversation.
In fact,
some moments in this conversation I
would say that they might be happier.
No,
it's been good.
It's been good.
So let me,
let me ask you a question here about
wellbeing because this is something I've
wanted to ask you about but we never
seem to get to is.
So you think that we should maximize
wellbeing and that's part of your
proposition,
which which I don't entirely disagree
with by the way that we should ground
our value starches in fact,
but,
but there's a black box problem.
They're like,
I think the black box problem about the
April restructure that we use to extract
the facts of the world out and the black
box problem is if we could measure
wellbeing,
it's like,
yeah,
that's a big problem Sam.
Like we have measures of wellbeing and
their terrible.
Yes they are.
No,
no,
I'm agreeing.
I think.
I don't think it's,
but it's not a problem for my thesis is
we don't have measures for anything we
care about.
But I mean,
if you're,
if your thesis is that if we had the
measures of wellbeing that were
appropriate,
we could use them in a positive way and
the responses,
but we don't have those measures.
It's like,
okay,
well then what do we do?
Oh No,
no,
but we have measures.
I mean,
this conversation is a measure.
I don't like that.
That's a measure,
right?
You step on my toe and I say out,
that's a measure.
Don't do that and get
for your wellbeing.
It might be a measure of your treat.
Neuroticism.
What it is a measure of.
I mean there's technically,
if you look at the wellbeing measures
that we have,
they degenerate it to measures of
neuroticism.
No,
we don't.
We don't.
But we don't have measures of certainty,
of belief,
of compassion,
of joy,
of,
of any,
any of these conscious states we have.
We have neural correlates of some of
them,
but we don't have.
We got,
there's no.
Well then how helmet writes about them
to Orient Ourselves in the world,
Dan,
because we're doing that.
We're doing this all the time.
If you've got an instantaneous measure
though,
you've got an instantaneous measure of
wellbeing,
we can all check with ourselves,
see how we feel,
but it's possible to be wrong about
that,
but,
uh,
it degrades as you get away from the
individual's ability to check internally
on the internal,
the internal thing isn't reliable or
happy when you're doing things that will
take a drug that would make you feel
very good and would cause you to take
apart your own life because it would be
like cocaine.
It would destroy the motivational
structure that gets you to do stumps,
stuff of value that,
uh,
that your rights,
we can't use emotion.
That emotion as an indicator of
instantaneous is not good,
but you have a parallel problem.
It looks to me like the exact mirror
image,
which is that you've got an integrative
long term measure of wellbeing
instantiated in an evolutionary belief
system,
but it's coming apart because we are
living in circumstances that are less
well mirrored.
The president does not mirror the past
and therefore these truths which you
believe are timeless or degrading.
Yeah,
rapidly.
That's part of.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
Okay,
so what Sam is arguing is that the tools
to pivot in order to improve our way of
interacting,
those are not the tools of long standing
tradition.
Those are the tools of rational
engagement,
respect for that process as part of the
longest standing tradition.
Yes,
that's true.
Yeah,
but that's a big truth,
man.
That's a major league truth.
In fact,
I would say the fundamental tradition
that most fundamental tradition of the
West says that respect for the process,
that updates moral judgment is the
highest of all possible values and
that's also built into the tradition.
Strangely enough,
I agree it's built into the,
into the tradition,
but I would argue that it is very likely
to be compartmentalized.
In other words.
I was a little bit struck when you said
that.
Um,
what did you say about scaling?
You said that,
uh,
the good reasons scale and batteries is
don't,
isn't that the opposite of the truth
calling if you're calling these stories
that give prescriptions for how to
behave bad ideas.
The point is those stories propagate
very easily,
was so.
Whereas,
so if we want to talk about the gun and
whether it is loaded,
the idea that the gun is definitely
loaded that scales really easily,
right?
You can pass that along in one sentence.
I'm wrong about a loaded gun also scale,
right?
So no,
no,
they're not.
Want to talk to
about very small possibilities of very
dire things happening.
They trip over it.
It's hard thing to get.
It's almost impossible for them to get
it.
So the point is the one thing does scale
story that says yeah,
every gun is loaded.
It's a false story,
but that one definitely scaled this
statistical reality of guns and the fact
that they may indeed beyond loaded,
but you don't want to play around with
the remote possibility that one day
you'll get it wrong,
right?
That doesn't scale because it requires
you to have experienced with stuff that
is not common.
Right?
Well,
so,
so the two things there,
one of you bring up as an ancillary but
very important point,
which is that moral progress here is
often the result of moving from our
story-driven protagonists driven
intuitions to something far more
quantified.
Right?
So I mean,
this is a classic,
you know,
moral study done by Paul Slovako,
I'm sure you are aware of where you tell
people about one needy little girl in
Africa and you give her a name and,
and,
and show her picture,
and what you elicit is the maximum,
our truest compassionate response from
subjects.
You go to another group of subjects,
you tell them about the same little
girl,
give her the same name,
but also tell them about her needy
little brother,
right?
Who has the same need and their response
diminishes,
right?
That just the addition of a single
person diminishes the response.
And this is just,
this is a moral fallacy that we're all
living out every day because if you care
about this one little girl,
you should care at least as much about
the fate of her and her brother.
And when you ask statistic,
no,
you shouldn't because this is a man.
You'll exhaust yourself in the attempt.
No,
because we need.
What do you wanting to know for 100
people?
This is what this,
this is what this software flog gets us.
It gets us people who will watch four
hours a day with,
with,
with effortless and and Peter Tear,
stained compassion,
the saga of the little girl who fell
down the well,
but who will blindly turn the channel
when they're hearing about a genocide
that is raging and there's a thousands
have already died.
Listen guys,
if you have something,
we have to.
If you for this know I'm not talking
about you're misunderstood.
You're misunderstanding me to great
effect here.
That if I'm not saying that you should
personally be overwhelmed by the death
toll every day you.
I'm not saying that it's functional for
you and I to each personally get up each
morning and just drink deep of the full
horror of all the bad luck that is
spread.
No,
maybe it is,
but maybe we can't have that,
but as societies we need.
When you're talking about how we report,
how we spend our money,
how we get a portion foreign aid,
the kinds of wars we fight or don't
fight,
it had to interpret.
Then we have to correct for what is in
fact a moral illusion,
which is we know that if we tell one
little,
we tell one compelling story about a
little girl,
right.
We could go to war over that.
Right.
Whereas we won't be motivated by a
genocide.
That's the kind of thing that moves
whole societies now and if,
if,
if it's.
If you add to it the bogus religious
sanctity,
he's,
if you,
if,
if we burn the Koran on this stage
tonight,
the rest of our.
Yeah,
the rest of our lives would be spent in
hiding,
right?
Because of how motivated people would be
to,
to address that pseudo problem.
Right.
That's the world we're living in and
we're at civilization so far as we have
a purchase on.
It is a matter of correcting for those
errors and religion for the most part,
not across the board,
but for the most part is standing in the
way of those course corrections.
Thank you.
Well,
okay.
There was a tremendous amount to unpack
in that.
I mean and,
and like in some sense,
a surprising amount.
It's like,
well,
we have,
we're,
we're wired to feel intense empathy for
individuals who are close to us and we
can be told stories in a manner that
that makes that system manifest itself
and everyone and their dog thinks that
that's a wonderful thing and we call
that empathy,
right,
and empathy has a narrow domain of
utility as it turns out,
because how?
I mean maybe if you were all who you
should be,
you'd be weeping constantly for the
catastrophic fate of sentient beings on
the earth,
but you can't handle it.
You know what I mean?
It's that you can barely handle your own
suffering and maybe you can handle a bit
of the suffering of your family and more
power to you.
If you could rectify that and if you
were better human beings,
maybe you could expand that outwards,
but the fact that our empathy doesn't
scale up to the level of genocide with
the same intensity that we treat
instances of individuals,
suffering isn't an indication that we're
irrational.
It's just an indication that we're
limited.
I think this is an indication of exactly
the problem
of our evolved structure is not matching
the present because the point is match
because we take care of our families
know,
but they don't match because if you
encountered the starving girl that's
some sort of a.
it's a crude measure of suffering in
your local environment.
Were you in the past now that you can
encounter this girl on the television?
It's not clear what it should mean to
you.
Right?
Right.
You can't calibrate how many your act
together.
Right,
and so the.
So the point is your indifference
to a genocide,
which is an abstraction,
right,
is altered.
Should you see pictures of the bodies,
for example,
you shouldn't actually feel differently
about the genocide in the abstract case
versus the the case that you're looking
at the bodies and the fact that we have
access to photo realistic
representations breading.
Of course that was actually a rational
because I can show you the case where
you care at level 10 about the little
girl named Lila and you care at level
eight about the little girl named Layla
and her brother named Jaunty.
Right?
And you care at level four if I've added
a few more kids,
but the little girl named Lila who you
was ostensibly care about is there and
each one of these,
right,
so nurses are diminished,
diminished nobody beautification of the
sufferer.
You have $10 to give away every month to
help start struggling in humanity and
you tell me you'll give 10 to lila this
month and I,
and then I catch you in another moment.
And I say,
well,
you know,
it's Leila and her brother.
So it's like,
if you only can give 10,
I understand,
but you know the problem is actually
worse than I suspected.
And you say,
well actually album's going to give
eight.
Right?
You,
it's not coherent with your how much you
cared about Leila and the first place
we do know we do know quite well.
The risks that we use to orient
ourselves in the world can be placed
into frameworks where they produce
contradictory outcomes.
But that doesn't mean that the
heuristics themselves are deeply flawed.
It's that it's a problem with the work
of people like condiment and diversity
is that we need to correct for that we
need to correct for them because they're
producing reliable results that we
recognize that you can put them in a
situation where they
produce a counterproductive response,
but that doesn't mean that generally
speaking,
in most situations they don't produce a
useful outcome because the question is
why in the hell would they evolved if
they didn't?
Most of the time evolved to live with
150 people with whom we're related and
to be terrified of the people in the
next valley who may want to kill and eat
us.
Yes,
and that's,
I mean,
that's our ancient circumstance which
doesn't map onto a common humanity of 7
billion people trying to figure out how
to get to Mars without killing each
other.
Well,
it does map onto it sometimes,
unfortunately,
because there are many times when we
still face the same kind of effect,
but hence,
look at maps.
Sean does the hierarchy.
You wouldn't be concerned about the
fundamentalists,
terror of Islam if you weren't driven by
those essentially tribal considerations
suggesting not trauma.
It doesn't require if my a mere
identification with humanity,
it can ground not wanting to be murdered
by people who are identified with a
subset of humanity.
Right?
Like I don't need to be part of a
smaller tribe to care that people will
murder me over burning the Koran.
Right?
It's,
it's,
it's just,
it's clearly counterproductive that we
live in a society where some objects are
held with such totemic attachment for
irrational reasons,
by many,
many millions of people were,
you know,
you should be sympathetic with this.
Our free speech is actually canceled on
this point,
right?
We literally can't produce cartoons.
I have scholarly words about the cartoon
price if we don't show the cartoon,
no argument whatsoever.
So if we miss about the lack of utility
of you,
you don't have to be identified as a,
as a Christian or a Jew to push back
against that.
You just have to be a human being that
sees the dysfunction of a smaller kind
of provincialism.
Well,
the thing that I'm struggling with is
that I still can't understand in what
your ethos is,
is is grounded because you claim like a
transcendental rationalism,
but you won't identify the structures
that produce it.
It's a black box and when I tried to
push you on the absolute nature of your
ethical claim,
which is that the bad life is worse than
the good life and that we should in fact
university work towards the good life.
It doesn't seem to me that you'll accept
the proposition that that's a universal
claim.
It.
No,
it is.
It is.
Well,
I should is irrelevant here.
It's just the fact that there is the
possibility of moving in this space.
If you move in the wrong direction,
if you move far enough,
you'll like it less and less,
but why is it relevant?
Give given the given the mines you have.
Well,
what if you had to accept moving in the
wrong direction and experiencing less
and less wellbeing in order to get to a
better place it.
Well,
and maybe even just to survive,
suppose the,
suppose the population has to endure a
generation and a half of misery in order
to persist
ethically,
that's a perfectly intelligible
circumstance that people have had to
face and it's in my,
on my moral landscape,
it's analogous to what we were were we
might be at one local maximum or some
high point,
but we're moving in a down a slope to
get to yet some higher place.
Right?
So certain things,
some things may only be possible if we
made some painful and net unpleasant
sacrifice for sure.
Yes.
And so that,
but that's,
that can be rationally apprehended.
There can be an argument for that.
It could be a way.
Well,
you know,
we all have to go on a diet,
otherwise we're going to,
we're going to die of this problem,
right?
We all have to stop eating whatever it
is,
wheat,
right?
It's a hard sacrifice for.
People will have to stop it as you know,
uh,
if that were just true wealth and
there'd be an argument for it,
there'd be evidence that would convince
us we would stop,
we would feel the pain and we would,
we would get whatever benefit with that
was on the other side of that sacrifice.
But again,
you don't have to,
if the utility again to come bring it
back to stories at which is,
as you know,
not my emphasis,
but it is yours.
The,
the utility of stories is not something
I'm arguing against.
I mean there's no question that certain
stories are incredibly compelling.
And in our conversation with one
another,
the moment you begin to frame something
in terms of a story,
people become much more interested right
now if,
if,
if 90 percent of what we said together
tonight,
we're afraid each,
each point we were making as a matter of
philosophy or,
or,
or science were framed in will.
Actually,
you know,
yesterday I was walking down the street
and I met this guy,
the terrifying looking guy and all of a
sudden people become much more
interested.
Right?
And then that's not an accident and that
says something deep about us that we
could understand that in evolutionary
terms and we might in fact one to
creatively leverage to be better people,
to have better conversations.
Definitely,
yes.
So that's what I think.
There's nothing.
There's nothing that I say in opposition
to religious dogmatism and religious
sectarianism that discounts that reality
and that's a psychological reality is a
cultural reality.
And I'm not against making the most of
it.
My,
my basic claim,
however,
is that we never need to believe that
one of our books may not have a human
origin.
In order to do that effectively,
you can.
You can be just as compelled by the
example of somebody like Jesus or some
more modern person who strikes you as a
moral hero and a deeply wise without
believing anything on insufficient
evidence.
And if,
as I,
as you alluded to,
purely fictional stories about
superheros can have immense effect on us
and that's something we could understand
and also leverage.
But again,
that takes us out of the religion
business and that's,
that's all I've been arguing for.
So do you really believe
that's
the belief in the supernatural aspect of
these stories,
never alters the calculus of what people
should do,
that the divine nature of a story about
Jesus doesn't motivate people to do
something that they might not have the
courage to do otherwise.
The belief that they might end up in
heaven because their good work is going
to be observed,
doesn't alter their behavior.
Well,
yeah,
I know it alters their behavior,
but rather often for the bad.
Well,
I mean this is why this is what worries
me about.
Hey,
I think there's something there.
There's a profound net negative that we
are paying the price for everyday by
believing in paradise,
right?
The belief,
a belief that this life,
it probably doesn't matter very much at
all because we get what we really want
after we die is forget about the
evidentiary basis for that belief.
It is.
It's ruinous for prioritizing what we
should be prioritizing in this life.
And if I agree with that,
by the way.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well that's interesting.
So let me ask you this,
I hear from you what might be a kind of
confirmation bias where I hear that,
you know,
we've got a mixed bag,
you've got supernatural claims,
these supernatural claims,
we all agree have effects on the way
people actually behave and you're quite
focused on the negative and you tend to
discount the positive which might be an
artifact of the fact that we're talking
about the present and therefore maybe
something that's not well matched to
these stories or it might be from the
idea that you have the sense that there
is actually a bias that these belief
structures do and have always produced
more harm than good.
And also my sense that the positive can
be had without those structures.
So they,
if you're talking about the,
the,
the contemplative experience like is it
possible to feed the wake up tomorrow
morning feeling like my heart right?
Feeling like you're just inseparable
from the pure capital b being that is
consciousness,
right?
And there's no separate self,
their,
the self transcending union with
everything you can proceed.
Right?
I think that can be had without any kind
of religious dogmatism masters that
matter of paying close enough attention
to the nature of consciousness,
so the contemplative life is the bay is
one baby in the bathwater.
We can save the ethical life is another
baby.
We can say if you don't have to
presuppose anything on insufficient
evidence to argue about what is right
and wrong and good and evil in in the
21st century.
Is it fair to call that a hypothesis
that not just for some people but for
everyone.
The level of wellbeing can be enhanced
through rational interaction with the
questions that dictate what we do.
Is that a hypothesis?
Whoa.
That's a hypothesis that the one
additional fact that we that makes that
more or less mood is that on certain
points,
even if we felt that really believe in
the fiction were what was it was
advantageous to people.
Depending on which fiction you're
talking about,
there's simply just.
There's too much evidence against it.
You can't.
You can't decide to believe something
for which you have no evidence simply
because of the good effects.
The good,
the good experience.
It will give you or you imagine it will
give you.
I mean,
that's.
That's why Pascal's wager never made any
sense.
We can't say the only way you can
believe something to be true,
really true,
not just metaphorically true,
is to believe that if it weren't true,
you wouldn't believe it.
They you stand at some relationship to
its truth such that that is the reason
why you believe it.
Now you can't say,
you can't be telling yourself,
you know,
I have no evidence for this thing,
but I know life would be better if I
believed that to true,
and so therefore,
I really believe it's true.
You don't think people do that all the
time?
I don't think they do.
I think they do things much more like
we're talking the metaphorical truth.
We're talking about you.
We act as if things are true without
forming any strong propositional claim
and that's fine.
That's fine.
That has its own utility.
You don't think this is
basically.
I mean,
we all suspend disbelief when we go and
watch a movie and we sort of entitled a
movie maker to,
to set the ground rules of the space and
if it's Harry Potter,
than there are magic magical things that
can happen and if it's some other story,
maybe there aren't.
So we all have a mechanism whereby we
know we can suspend disbelief and it's
interesting to me that you seem not to
imagine that people are doing that with
respect to metaphysical beliefs that
have implications for what the right
actions that they should take art.
Why?
Why wouldn't it be the case that that
same sort of mechanism would apply?
Well,
it does apply,
but there are people who are clearly
doing much more than that.
So I'm not.
If,
if that's all people were doing under
the ages of religion,
I wouldn't spend much time worrying
about religion,
but that to some degree that's what
people do.
You know,
as you say,
go into caring about things that I
bought them we really shouldn't care
about.
So the World Cup is on right now and we
literally billions of people care care
down to their toes.
What happens to this little ball as it
traverses a lawn.
Right?
And if it goes into the net,
it really matters if it fails to,
it really matters and always matters if
we hit the target Sam.
But this is,
this is something we have manufactured
to care about,
right?
It speaks to us.
It's quite literally a game,
a game that people are playing.
But some people take it in taking it
further than you,
than,
than seems truly rational is part of the
fun.
That's but,
but the fee that the people who can't
turn that off metaphor soccer's a
metaphor but there.
But there are people who there,
you know,
there are people,
you know the,
the fullback who kicks an own goal and
then goes back to his South American
village and gets murdered.
Right?
He's surrounded by people who are taking
the game too seriously.
Yeah.
Okay.
I agree.
Yeah.
And so my problem with religion is that
so much of a time we're meeting those
people and we're at work and we're not
criticizing those people.
We have no place to stand to criticize
those people because
so attached to the game.
Fair enough.
Why don't we do this?
Why don't we each take three minutes to
sum up.
So I think,
yeah,
we are there.
We're at the end of time.
So why don't you each take three
minutes,
some up and then we'll call it.
Good.
Okay.
I'm sure Sam went last.
Do you want to go first here?
Okay.
So there's lots of things about which
seminar.
I agree,
but the devil's in the details.
Of course.
Now I,
I'm very sympathetic to his claim that
we need to ground our ethical systems in
something solid and demonstrable.
My problem is I'm not sure how to do
that when I don't believe that you can
derive a value structure from your
experience of the observable facts.
There's too many facts.
You need a structure to interpret them
and there isn't very much of you.
And so part of the reason,
part of the way that that's addressed
neurologically is that you have an
inbuilt structure.
It's deep,
it's partly biological,
it's partly an emergent consequences of
your socialization and you view the
world of facts through that structure
and it's a structure of value.
Now that structure of value may be
derived from the world of facts over the
evolutionary timeframe,
but it's not derived from the world of
facts over the timeframe that you
inhabit and it can't be.
So.
The problem I have with our discussion
so far isn't really any of Sam's
fundamental ethical claims because I do
believe there's a distinction between
the hellish life and the heavenly life
say the life that everyone would agree
with absolutely not worth living and the
life we could imagine as good.
And I do believe that we should be
moving from one to the other.
The question is exactly how is it that
we make the decisions that will guide us
along that way.
And I don't believe we can make them
without that April to restructure.
In fact,
I think the evidence is absolutely
overwhelming that we can't.
And I mean also the scientific evidence
and I would like to go further into the
devil that's in those details.
And so that's my situation.
Thanks.
Hope part of these conversations.
And now if you,
and I've had I think four conference
done,
two podcasts in this or a second live
event.
And thank you for doing this.
By the way,
this is,
hey,
it's my pleasure,
honor to do this.
And it's,
uh,
it comes with risks for both of us to do
this.
I think you can sense we don't have
precisely the same audiences.
All of you are sort of rooting for one
or the other of us to some degree for
the spirit of truth.
And
yes,
but clearly
the conversation is the point,
right?
This is not though this conversation,
the character at many moments of a
debate,
I don't think either of us view it as a
debate in,
in the trivial sense is not about point
scoring.
It's about making sense in a way that's
consequential because we're talking
about issues of great consequence and
you obviously care about these things
and it matters whether we converge on
the most important questions in human
life and as you know,
I'm worried that religion doesn't give
us the tools we need to converge what
does give us the tools is a truly open
ended conversation and then you simply
have to look honestly at the obstacles
toward any conversation.
Being open ended and religion presents
those first and most readily.
It's.
It is a had the idea that certain things
have been decided for all time and
there's no future evidence or argument
that is admissible on those points.
Now that is clearly bad.
Everywhere in science.
It's bad everywhere in in how we
renegotiate our proximity to one another
in society.
It a new laws and new ideas are born all
the time about how to structure
institutions and social relationships
because new things happen.
I mean,
we didn't have an internet and then we
did,
so our old laws and our old expectations
of human communication simply don't work
in the presence of this new thing.
Right?
So we have to figure out.
We,
again,
it's a navigation problem and what I'm
perpetually in contest when even in
conversations like this is the sense
that the rules need to change just a
little bit for this class of books that
literally this side of the bookstore,
right?
There's like any other part of the
bookstore will then there's no barrier
to honest conversation,
but you move over here.
They got this shelf of books there.
You have to hold your tongue right
there.
We can't pick and choose.
We can't say that.
While we can say that Shakespeare wrote
some fantastic players,
the best players ever written and some
are actually not that good,
right?
We can't say that about God,
We have to find some tortured way to
make the most of his diabolical
utterances.
Right.
That's the thing we have to outgrow and
so what I'm continually intention with
you is the degree to which your style of
talking about religion and narrow the
power of narrative and the meaning
derived from it aligns that point and
seems to let people off the hook on that
very point and that's the.
That's where we need to hold the line.
In my view,
we need to.
We need to
sure
that,
that it has to be clear to us at this
moment in history that no one has the
right to their religious sectarianism.
Really.
I mean it it up to the point.
Clearly there's a soccer,
there's a World Cup version of it that
has benign,
but once it gets taken past that point,
we we have to figure out how to pull the
brakes and that becomes a real problem.
If your.
If you going to dignify the foundational
claims of these faiths claims like
revelation and paradise and blast
swimming and apostasy,
and these are things that you come up
against and I think conversations like
this are incredibly important because we
need to convince the better part of
humanity that is possible to live the
best life possible without recourse to
divisive nonsense and where we draw the
line between divisive nonsense and
reasoned,
unnecessary discourse is what we're,
we're dickering over and I think,
I think it's important that we continue.
Thank you.
In closing,
let me say,
first of all,
I'm tremendously honored that you asked
me to moderate these debates.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
It was a truly remarkable experience.
As for what was accomplished,
I think it was a tremendous amount.
I saw both of you move.
I saw both of you exhibit tremendous
generosity of spirit towards the other
and I think,
um,
this has exceeded my expectations of
what might've been possible in these
discussions by quite a bit.
Um,
and that also I will say,
has a lot to do with the fact that for
reasons I think none of us can explain a
huge amount of people,
a huge population seems to care about
these issues because they matter a great
deal.
So anyway,
I think this has been a very successful
exercise and I think you both justly be
quite proud of what you've done.
Alright,
let's give a huge round of applause.
Thank you.
Thanks.